Oh No,
no,
here we go.
Good.
Here we go.
Three
to live.
Boom.
We live.
Gentlemen.
Joe Freda.
Hey,
good to be here.
Good to see you guys.
It's happening.
Not much.
We're in Sunny California.
Yeah,
it's a too close to the sun.
A little bit barbecued over the last
week and a half.
I've been hiding in a hotel for six
days.
How proper that we're here to talk
about,
uh,
the apocalypse.
I was going to say your book is Joe
Beef.
Surviving the apocalypse.
I'm a cookbook for surviving the
apocalypse.
What is the,
what's the purpose of the,
uh,
the title?
Just a goof.
We haven't written a book in years.
I don't think we really wanted to write
a second book.
Uh,
when we started getting a bit of
pressure to write a second one,
we Kinda,
you know,
laid down the gauntlet to the editors
and said,
we're going to write what we want.
Are you in,
are you out?
And they said,
well,
you know,
show us a little bit of the framework of
that this is going to be.
I said,
I want to talk.
I mean,
I'll cooking doesn't define me or Fred
to stop all that we do.
Like it's,
you know,
you see some people,
they seem to like eat live and breathe
cooking.
I said,
no man,
I'm into the outdoors.
I meant the mushroom picking.
I meant the fermentation of berries.
I'm into canoeing.
I know all about canoes.
I love swimming in lakes.
I want to talk about multiple subjects.
I want to talk about the native Mohawks
of Quebec.
I wanted,
you know,
so I said,
let us write a book about the multiple
subjects of which were into,
you know,
a joy.
If we're not cooking,
we're building first they'd get in
survival gets for real,
really goes to like ll bean.
He has a lifetime membership there and I
have an off grade cabin up north,
like north of Montreal,
about an hour and a half.
You can only get there by,
by boat,
a say kilometers from the landing,
a 2000 watts of solar power.
Completely off grid.
You can't even,
you can barely walk in because of the
jagged cliffs all around it.
And behind me is an old growth forest
that's protected federally and I have a
suture kit and salient my car always
cars outfitted,
like he's got shovels on the roof and a
propane tanks on the roof.
Two years ago I drove to Alaska down
South Arizona,
back home.
Wow.
Twenty thousand miles.
I grew up in Boston and I did stand up
in Montreal for the first time I think
in like 1991 or something like that.
And I remember thinking Boston was cold
until I went to Montreal and I went,
Oh,
this is a different things.
We had the polar vortex last year come
roaring through.
I think all the pipes blue in all the
restaurants I'm sure like January
second,
you know,
boy,
I was going to say is,
do you think that living in such an
extreme environment in a beautiful city,
amazing city,
but it's an incredibly harsh environment
in the winter.
Do you think that makes you more,
uh,
more cognizant?
It's always the need for survival.
It's always in the back of my head.
I have three daughters,
like I saw always in the back of my
head.
And said,
this is incredibly cold.
If the power goes out for 48 hours,
I have to start a plan b.
where am I bringing my babies?
What are we going to eat?
Where are we going to fit our city?
Over the last couple of years I've been
talking about a complete ban of
fireplaces and wood burning stoves
inside of homes,
condominiums and Hoe and houses,
the laws governing wood burning and the
city of Montreal are stricter than the
ones in California.
Uh,
and we'd die.
Man,
if we die,
I go,
this is irresponsible,
you know,
by the government to do this.
I said,
okay,
make sure we don't use them,
but let's all have them just in case.
Same goes for.
Because if a bit,
what are they worried about it for?
They're worried about their admission
particulates.
Yes,
correct man.
But it smells good.
Like a nice woodburnings doesn't like
this affects everybody.
This affects restaurants and grilling
food.
This affects barbecue.
This effects or you know,
a traditional bagels stores.
Traditional bagels stores.
Cook with wood as I already said that.
Of course you go into Thailand,
St Theater,
Bagel,
fairmount,
all the other ones you smell it.
It's a massive part of our culture as
well.
You have to understand that food wise,
the province of Quebec,
the city of Quebec City and Montreal,
she's a first place is populated in
North America.
This is,
you know,
the Europeans to,
to get to anywhere in North America.
Came through Quebec First New York
afterwards.
The food culture in Quebec is over 400
years old.
You can't say that about over a thousand
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And then wood,
wood,
what is detrimental to that if it wasn't
for burning wood,
I'm not saying we should do it for
historical purpose,
but like man,
like if we run out of gas,
there's still would give you a ticket,
you know,
two grand because you're having a fire.
A few years ago,
about a decade ago,
we had this crazy ice storm in Quebec,
you know,
the perfect storm of rain and then cold
and then rain and then cold.
All the power lines without the pylons
crashing.
Got Thick with ice,
right?
Yeah.
For two weeks.
Yeah,
two weeks and there's a baby boom right
after that because people stayed home,
no television and no heat and then
procreated.
Then there was a true baby boom.
Nine months later there was a ton of new
kids born.
That's hilarious.
Do you know the,
the deep freeze.
It also cleans the city in the winter,
so from your perspective,
the shit hits the fan and come and see
us because it,
it's a pretty good city to survive
anything,
you know?
It's a pretty neat place because the
winter just sanitizes everything.
You start again every year.
Yeah.
As opposed to la where you never really
get that cleaned
down.
You'll never have a long haul.
Yeah,
you do like a horse bath,
you know,
you just get it like a year in a
restroom somewhere with paper towels
that you went down and sort of get your
underarms or whatever.
That's what La is,
the wet towel,
let's.
Yes,
yes.
So you just wanted to write a book that
kind of covers all of your interests,
not just with food,
but one of the things that I really
enjoyed about there was an episode that
you guys did have a Anthony Bourdain's
show where you were ice fishing and you
had one of those ice fishing huts
and you get into cooked it.
Tony told you it's notorious and they
show that they never caught fish and
whenever he had a gun he never hit
anything.
So we knew that we knew that there was
not a pike and there was not a Walleye
that was going to bite.
So we're like,
okay,
option a.
We sit there and take some fake fish and
we fry it up in cornflakes,
in shortening.
And the hollow cabin where we just went
like joe beef crazy.
And we brought all the old cookbooks.
We add all the spirits,
like Cuban cigars,
all the copper where all this stuff.
And we made the menu from an Old Leon,
a restaurant,
Paul bocuse that he did a show at after
and in.
He knew nothing about that day and we
just went from fishing after he asked us
about like strippers and Quebec and just
a few funny banter and it was.
We just went in and was like magical.
It's.
It was seriously fence a 10th of the
size of this room here.
Yeah.
It was a tiny,
tiny little shack and he tapped out that
day.
Yeah.
He was having a good time and we hit
that.
We brought some fine wines and fine
spirits from some really rare oddities.
Some old charts,
rows and stuff like that that Fred had
lying around
and,
and Tony was,
was fun as arts up on the screen right
there.
He let it go a bit,
you know,
he just,
he calmed down and enjoyed us and let us
do our thing.
I'm a bit fatter.
Oh God.
Those in the wine drinking days too,
right?
Yeah,
correct.
Look at that.
God,
that looks good.
Is that Fagua in some sort of mashed
potatoes or something?
Yeah,
that's a wild rabbit.
It's a French recipe.
It's gold hair a lot.
Were you,
you cook the hair for a long time and
hair and you serve it with truffles and
you take,
you keep the blood.
This hair is snared so it's still full
of blood and you keep the blood and at
the end you thicken the sauce with the
blood flow.
All right.
It's very good and I bet you,
you know,
it's funny.
I bet you a fits all the principles of
nutrition.
Now you know it's like blood and all the
organ meats and all the same with
cheese.
Look,
this is like the airport right there,
isn't it?
That is interesting,
right?
That no one
thought of that until recently that that
was what it was,
that people just thought of it as cheese
and now people think of it as there's
live cultures on it and Oregon meat is
much healthier for you and people are so
much more.
Look at the cheese thing too.
It's like nowadays a lot of the
probiotic makers are doing like a light
bulb.
Deliveries.
They coded in fat so it resists the
stomach acid.
Right?
But that's fat probiotic from Jesus
covered in fat.
You did after your dinner,
it lives through you and it all in a
perfect world that comes from right
around your house.
Right?
So you eat a cheese and the probiotics
are the same one that you're going to
encounter later.
So you kind of get immunized in a way
that's the benefit.
That's what true local is,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
Is there
benefit to eating cheese after meal?
Yeah,
sure it is.
When it's a very pungent,
uh,
advanced alive raw cheese,
it'll be seen ultimately as a
nonalcoholic Dj Steve,
what does a Dj to,
to,
to help stimulate digestion?
Oh no kidding.
So it's almost like an enzyme,
like a,
like a probiotic,
but mostly.
And now they're,
they're figuring this out that the
problem of the low fat diet than the,
you know,
like brown rice and chicken breast,
the bodybuilder diet.
Nothing triggers your fullness because
they realized that fat actually makes
you full quite fast.
Right?
So if you eat a bit of cheese,
you're done.
You tap out after,
you don't need like a full plate of
cheese or layered on a hamburger,
but just a little bit of cheese after
just cuts you off and then you have
spirits and cigars are not that healthy,
but
yeah,
I've been talking about that with a lot
of nutrition experts where they say that
your body,
when it eats a lot of carbohydrates,
you can consume carbohydrates far past
what you actually need.
Whereas if you're just eating a lot of
fat and protein,
your body tends to regulate itself much
better.
Satiate.
Yeah.
Now you guys,
how long have you been in Montreal and
then I have to tell you,
and I've said it before,
if I had a say my all time favorite
restaurant.
I think joe beefs my all time favorite
I don't like to say my all time number
because there's a lot of great
restaurants in this world,
but damn,
if I had to choose one,
I think I might choose.
You guys know you're very kind,
but we have to take you out to other
places to change your mind.
I don't think you've got a man,
you guys are the kind of,
if you're a horse lover,
turn your head,
plug your ears,
you guys.
The first people that ever served me
horse and I was like,
what?
When he brought over,
it was a horse horse tenderloin and I
was like,
what the fuck?
You guys are eating horse up here and
horse tar tar.
But it's a stigma,
you know,
let's say a cow and Elica buys in a deer
forest.
It's four legged animal and you know
what if I put,
if I put a buys in tenderloin and serve
you a beef tenderloin and a cow
tenderloin and that deer tender lights,
at the end of the day it's,
you know,
it's just has a couple of degrees of
separation from the other.
It's all flesh really.
It's,
it's very subjective that we base or
nutritional choices and how pretty or
how cute an animal is,
you know,
it doesn't make sense.
You know,
and we're lucky now we're able to choose
where we eat.
It wasn't like that a hundred years ago.
You know,
the purpose of the food guide until like
40 years ago was to make sure you had
enough galleries.
Now we're in an age of restriction,
so we like,
I don't
want horse,
I prefer deer or I prefer veal or add
chicken yesterday.
Can't have twice a neuro.
Like all this is a bit of fluff,
what we do in a way because we're so
fortunate to have enough food to decide.
Remy Warren was on a backpacking,
horseback elk hunt and one of the horses
fell down,
broke its leg,
and they had to make a decision.
They were deep in the back country and
they had to shoot it and it was just
wasn't gonna get out of there.
And after they shot it,
he decided that really this sound was
going to go to waste.
So they took the back straps off and
they cooked it and ate it and they said
it was a really weird moment where like,
this is the animal that was like
everybody's petting it.
And it was,
you were,
you know,
you're riding it and it just,
it was a working animal,
but it was an animal that you loved and
then all of a sudden it's down and you
have to kill it.
And he's like,
well,
it's going to go to waste.
He said,
it just felt wrong to let it go,
to waste.
So they cut the backstraps off of it.
The
other reason I think we don't eat horace
culturally is really based ultimately on
the battle of Wolf between Mount Column
on the plains of Quebec City.
Uh,
you know,
that was a decisive battle in North
American history.
Whereas if the French had won that
battle,
everybody in North America,
ultimately we'd be speaking French.
You know,
they didn't win that battle.
So British rule imposed.
So in England you did indeed horace by
royal decree,
but in the franchise horace,
the Belgians had horse,
the Germans eat horse,
you see.
So that's what it is.
Very old history,
you know,
it was mining,
it was potent and anglophone world.
We'd Horace and,
and,
and all the mining countries.
A half.
My family's from Belgium.
And it's traditional there because they
bring the horse in,
the mine,
the horse,
you know,
sad for a horse to live in the mind,
in the dark.
But they wouldn't bring it out when he
was old,
you know,
they would just eat the horse.
Most cultures eat Turkish,
eat horse know.
Well,
it was a necessity.
I mean,
you couldn't pick and choose back when
all this was instituted.
We're very limited in the proteins that
we eat.
And especially in North America,
Quebec last.
So you know,
Quebec has a very openminded dining,
public,
very advanced dining public,
very old dining public,
and of course Latin French dining,
public.
The amount of proteins that are served
in a Montreal restaurant are numerous
compared to,
let's say,
even when I go to Manhattan,
if me and you and Fred are in Manhattan
tomorrow night,
say,
let's go have rabbit with mustard sauce,
it's going to be a tough sell.
We're going to really struggle to find
rabbit mustard sauce.
We're going to struggle even to find a,
you know,
let's go have a couple of slices of
liver tonight with onions.
It's gonna be very difficult.
Solid lab,
NAC liver deer is a hard,
tall order,
you know,
intimately Manhattan or America eats a
limited scope of proteins,
beef,
chicken,
so forth.
Whereas,
you know,
French culture,
Quebec,
you
know,
we have all the proteins.
I have young dining clientele that have
no problem eating kidneys,
medium rare,
a liver,
lamb,
liver,
dear neck,
dear heart,
tar tar.
It's not a thing like it's not what
other restaurant people are eating.
Part of the registry and little girl.
It was like your daughters raised
eating,
you know,
the food that their dad hunts and the
food that their parents by some people
of lesser means eat pork liver raised on
it.
So when they see liver on the
restaurant,
cute little,
you know,
a 19 year old girls that are about to go
out to the club later but have a slice
of liver.
You won't see that.
New York City.
Are you allowed to sell Benison in here
that you hunt?
No,
not that you hunt.
You have to buy by farm raised stuff and
oddly enough,
most of it's from New Zealand.
Most of the stuff that we're getting
here in the United States is from New
Zealand and if they call it venison,
it's most likely some sort of stag or
you know,
and the elk that we get,
if we buy Elkanah restaurant,
it's all from New Zealand harvest.
When you,
when you do a kill,
you can put it in your freezer.
Okay,
perfect.
Yeah,
we'll all,
I have two freezers back here.
Um,
all of,
um,
the elk that I get,
I get for myself that I hunt and I give
it to a lot of my friends and I make
sausages from my friends and I sent,
you know,
but that's the only way they're gonna
get it unless they go out and get it
themselves.
It's not a place in Los Angeles where
you can go by elk meat and new in
Newfoundland that they're allowed to.
Hunters are allowed to sell moose back
to the restaurants.
Really?
Yeah.
Moose for introduced onto the island of
Newfoundland from Maine.
And there was no natural predators on
Newfoundland.
So the mood and it's a perfect
environment for them.
So they just propagated.
So that's why they take drive slow.
They're we shot with Tony,
they drove slow,
like we drove for hours,
like full days to go like 300 miles
because you can't drive fast because of
the Moose is so you can have a
restaurant in the hotel.
We stayed,
the restaurant had a permit to buy Moose
so they would make like Moose curry and
moves us days in kind of vibe.
Like I'm not a great restaurant,
like a hotel,
a hotel restaurant serving wild moose
burgers.
But it's pretty cool that they do that.
That is cool.
But if they did that everywhere else,
then we're just reinventing the wheel,
you know,
we're rolling.
We're going back to market hunting,
which is what almost wiped out almost
all of the animals in this country.
And some shops in Quebec would like to
bring that back.
And I,
you know,
I said listen,
we can barely manage our roads,
our infrastructure,
we can barely manage like our.
And that's the risk of foraging through
it.
Like eventually,
you know,
like people go for mushrooms.
It's like you heard about the fights
between the mushroom pickers in Oregon
and stuff like that.
We're no.
Oh fuck.
Like the people who harvest clams do it.
They'd like between the communities.
There's huge fights for territories and
they hijack like trucks of abalone at
night and gooey duck.
The giant King Clam.
Yeah.
I've heard stories of a guide on an
economy line van with 500 pounds of
gooey duck going
to the Victoria airport to send them to
Japan,
get hijacked on the highway at night and
they steal the clams because they're
worth a fortune in Japan and same for
mushroom matsutake.
Mushrooms are as well and other earth is
famous white.
It's called a pine mushroom and then
Japan to matsutake mushrooms.
The closer,
the shape of the mushroom to a penis,
the more expensive it is,
you know,
so they like,
they actually hijack people in their way
through the patch and like undressed
them and make them turn around so they
can never find the place again.
Wow.
This competitive Morel mushrooms.
You look a morel mushroom.
It's a.
You know,
how much Fred for very expensive?
40 four bucks a kilo in Montreal and
pull this a little closer to just
credit.
Keep it brought up fist from your face.
Yeah,
the Morel Mushrooms.
I buy them online.
They're very expensive.
I buy them dried and they're so
delicious.
I mean people who don't like mushrooms,
like one of my daughters does not like
mushrooms,
but she loves morale.
It's my favorite.
It's a number one mushroom.
Good with salted,
with garlic,
salt and sauteed in butter.
They're sensational.
Great Mushroom,
strange flavor.
One of our favorite.
There's a great recipe for that in the
book is poached chicken legs,
right until they're ready and then into
the broth.
Very little broth.
You know,
you strain the broth,
you add cream and salt.
They Morel mushrooms in there and a
little bit of Sherry wine.
Any of oxidized wine and you just add
the legs in there and you let you let
that simmer.
Man.
That's good.
We have a picture in the book of some
Morel Mushrooms are the size of these
water bottles.
We've had morel mushrooms that are about
the size of my hand.
You can stuff like half a chicken leg
inside of them and serve one stuff.
Morel mushroom and Bra for one customer.
It's brilliant.
They're a strange mushroom,
right?
Where they.
They pop up after burns.
Yeah,
and they also have spraying mushroom,
which is weird because most of the other
mushrooms or later on damp.
Right.
And morale is like literally quite quick
after the snow.
That's the first mushroom that appears
in the forest.
So it's a very different than all the
others.
Are they commercially cultivated?
They could be,
but not.
I've never seen it.
My career tried growing mushrooms.
We tried everything at the restaurant.
I tried growing mushrooms and like you
get everything but the mushroom,
you inoculate,
it was very difficult to keep the proper
conditions and stuff.
That's why I'm not against the fact that
they're expensive,
you know,
it's a good way to regulate a market
price,
you know?
It's like,
yeah,
you know,
bluefin tuna is going extinct,
but just make it three times the price.
It's going to regulate the market.
You know?
I guess I wish there was a way to
reintroduce Bluefin to the wild.
It's just seems like the appetite that
people have for those things,
it's just untenable.
Give you a look at any given night in a
city like Manhattan,
how much red tuna is sold on the island
of Manhattan any given night of the
year.
It's,
it's,
it's scary.
I almost feel like it's like killing the
last giraffe in a herd like fishing a
giant tuna like that.
It's and again,
you know that they're big,
they're feisty.
They're majestic,
so that should in guide my choice,
my decision and to protect them.
But like I said,
that's heartbreaking.
The problem is the complete lack of
regulation on the open waters when these
guys have these enormous ships filled
with huge nance and just drag them
across the ocean floor and capture
everything that you catch.
And that's the biggest disconnect.
It's like they call it bycatch.
So you didn't set up the fish for tuna,
but that's what kind of bit,
you know,
like,
yeah,
come on.
You know,
you go fishing for what?
To catch a Bluefin tuna in the first
place,
you know,
place.
Oh,
so they're,
they're,
they're pretending they're not fishing
for it.
Is that what you're saying?
Oh,
allegedly.
Well,
you know,
that whole thing was Japanese whalers.
They found a way to work around it and
the way the world's largest science
research posts,
so the science research where we're
going to do research on these whales
that we kill and then they chop them up
and sell them and sea shepherd has been
tracking that down and they hover over
them and take photographs of it and
report them and now it's ugly business,
ugly business.
We've worked hard at the restaurant
until I'm ultimately avoid it to be more
seafood,
sustainable seafood focused.
You know,
the oyster is a great thing to eat.
We should eat oysters,
clams,
Florida.
Oddly as an amazing sustainable seafood
scene.
You know,
just the work that they do with the
Florida stone crab,
right?
You know that every year they just
harvest like the left arm and they put,
they put the crap back and the next year
it's the right arm and they put the crab
back real.
Yeah.
It's a brilliant fishing industry.
They don't kill the animal,
the clog rows back and it's a side
side-by-side sound like that.
You're telling me something good about
Florida,
they have a great shrimping,
seen a great,
that they're actually leaders in
sustainable seafood.
Seafood and fishing is such a gigantic
part of their economy.
It makes sense that they would do that.
That's a smart thing.
Grouper fishing down there is a giant,
giant part of there.
There's a good book that was published a
few years ago.
The big oyster,
I think mark Galinsky,
he wrote a book about the history of the
oyster,
the New York and the history of the
oyster.
That's incredible.
Super interesting because this is his
thing was like,
you know,
we try to portray or history as glorious
and we heard it bisons before for
protein and that's how we started like
modern farming,
but in fact we probably farmed oysters
and snails and clients because they
don't move and they are the most
prolific and the most abundant source of
protein in that book are landscape
brings up a premise,
and I'm loosely interpreting it now
because I read this book a few years
ago,
but think of this for a second,
right?
The island of Manhattan a is a perfect.
All the rivers around it,
all the water systems around it is
actually one of the greater oyster
situations
on the Atlantic east coast,
right.
The reason that the population exploded
in Manhattan in the early days was that
any person could literally get off a
boat,
walk onto the island of Manhattan
homeless,
broke and sleeping an alley and walk
down to the river and pick five oysters.
A small oyster is five grams of protein,
right?
A medium oysters got 10 grams of
protein,
so completely destitute person could
just eat six oysters a day,
you know,
three oysters and live again another day
to find a job.
So the population ultimately,
you know,
New York City and its population was
based on this readily supply,
this huge supply of oysters.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's free.
Available source of protein that will
make you live another 24 hours.
So if it takes you three days to find a
job for days to find a job at 20 days to
find a job,
you're not going to die because there's
oysters.
Look at this and yeah,
and they,
they,
they found from the fuck.
What is this from Harlem River Oysters.
Credible.
Yeah.
There's a actual islands that they
thought were like Geo geological
formation that are made of oyster
shells.
This layers and layers of oyster shells.
The article that Jamie put up is from
thrillist is I would pull up to the top
so I can tell people the order,
the news,
why oysters are ridiculously important
to the history of New York City and it
just showing all these ancient photos of
mounds of oyster shells and is an
amazing program today.
You know,
some of the areas that there's.
That they take these giant cages.
One Oyster,
if I'm correct,
oyster filters for metric tons of water
per day.
From what I understand,
I might be wrong with my math,
so take this.
For instance,
you know a cage,
a cage box of thousands of oysters.
There it is.
Single Oyster can filter about 30 to 50
gallons of water every day.
Little loose math job,
digital New York's waterways on exactly
the cleanest the folks behind the
billion oyster project or trying to
change that by recycling shells from the
part,
partnering restaurants and getting them
back in the water to build oyster reefs.
The goal is to add a billion oysters to
the water by 20,
35.
So far they're restored.
One point.
Oh,
one acre.
One point five acres of reason.
Well,
don't say one point.
Oh,
five bid sheet.
You got an acre.
Oh,
that's you just add in those extra two
numbers.
One point.
Oh,
five acres of reefs and count 11 point 5
million.
Newly grown oysters.
But the oysters will clarify the water.
It'll make a murky river clear again.
Wow.
But it didn't affect the taste of the
oyster.
They don't eat those oysters.
I think those are pulled back into
landfill after or mulched into gardens
or for.
The shells are banned from where reef.
But the oyster is interesting.
It doesn't.
Right?
It opens its shells to the feed,
showing how they do it.
This is incredible.
And the oyster,
you know that the oyster has a.
It will change gender according to the
density of the population,
so it'll go from male to female in order
to balance the center.
That's incredible.
We're watching a video where the.
What is it?
The oyster recovery was.
It was the timeline.
Oh,
sorry.
So it's a timelapse,
but it said what,
what does it say?
It was from a filtration.
Right.
But there was a watermark on the video
there on the corner.
It was showing receipts.
Yeah.
Oyster recovery partnership.
So the watermark is.
So what they do is they have this
horrible green water chuck these oysters
in and it turns it completely clear.
That's amazing.
I did not know that.
I didn't know that they used to eat
lobsters and they thought of lobster
says poor people food out of the river
in New Brunswick.
They used to,
um,
harvests lobsters to feed to the
prisoners and keep the shells as
fertilizer.
The Jefferson was one of the first
presidents to bring the lobster into the
White House because it was seen as
servants food.
When did it switch Jefferson?
So when he started doing that,
that's when people realized it was so
delicious.
Lobster socially will be,
if we changed the whole thing,
the lobsters could get a job is insane.
That lobster spaghetti that's uh,
that's off the charts,
you know,
so the child labor laws were in stored
primarily because of the kids that used
to work in an oyster.
Shucking plants.
Really?
Yeah.
We had a,
one of our best friend,
if not our best friend,
passed away like six months ago.
John Bill,
he was a great chucker you helped us at
the Barbara.
He was like deep into sustainability and
history of oysters and everything and he
was like the source for oysters for
everything.
He wrote a beautiful book.
I will send you a copy.
It's an incredible book.
There are good food for vegans to
consider too because there are more
primitive than most plants.
Yeah.
Know.
Smallest.
John used to call them ocean cupcakes
are delicious.
It's a great source of protein,
but it's also they don't have any nerve
endings.
They're not feeling any sea vegetable.
Yeah.
It basically is.
We have an issue or some people,
not myself,
but some people have an issue with
things that are capable of moving for
whatever reason,
we just decided that don't eat that,
but if you want to talk about something
sustainable like mollusks and seafood
and I mean they can be commercially
farmed.
They,
they actually do have a positive impact
as you're describing on the environment
and credible source of protein as well.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and really owned her complete source of
protein.
Not like a very bioavailable source,
unlike a lot of vegetable proteins.
So maybe we should do a protein powder
out of dried oysters.
Just moisture,
protein bro.
I mean a lot of people are eating
cricket protein.
If you guys ever serve any insect dishes
really well.
One of the things,
I got a letter last week that someone
found bug in their salad in there.
I know sometimes the people are a bit.
They want the cake and they went to eat
it too because they people want organic
and we support that.
We love that,
but yeah,
organic.
There's no pesticides,
so that's okay.
The bugs aren't bad.
It's like the idea of bugs being like
roaches are bad.
Okay.
Most other bugs are not that big of a
deal.
It's like quite,
you know,
if we're serving,
we're serving 100 people a day and maybe
that arguably being 40 solid,
you know,
some kind of crazy work to really look
at both sides of each leaf.
We try our best,
you know,
but you know,
one at one will get past us every year.
I think you're better off the people
that,
that are freaking out about bugs.
You don't want them coming in there.
Just let them just give them their money
back and get the fuck out of here.
Yeah,
I agree with that policy.
But when I was in Mexico,
they uh,
we checked into this resort and they had
a bowl of fried crickets in the hotel.
Like they had some sort of a flavor to
them.
They added some flavor to.
Yeah.
Rene Redzepi and noma.
Arguably one of the world's best
restaurants is obsessed with serving
ads.
Really loves them.
Lemony fresh.
I don't know.
I think that,
I think they're crunchy.
They're delicious.
Uh,
you know,
he thinks they're fine,
of course,
and he's doing this wonderful nordic
cuisine and there's ants and vegetables
and they foraged mushrooms and there's
also ad.
So why not forge those two and it's a
homework they do for the rest of us,
you know,
it starts there,
they're doing the right thing,
you know,
people pay a lot of money,
flight there to go eat there,
but you know,
he's doing some good legwork and how to
prepare them,
how to raise them,
how to,
you know,
I'm not saying it's food is based on
that,
but I'm happy that somebody did that
part of the research and he'll bring the
point up and that'll,
you know,
ultimately by Osmosis,
other younger chefs will try to do that.
I know will tell you.
It'll normalize it a little bit more.
So expect aunt at Nordic restaurants.
Interesting.
So this is the new trend.
Get ahead.
Have you heard them?
Los Angeles.
I know you trendy fox are out there
thinking about what's coming.
I'm crickets or a weird one.
Like cricket seemed to be like
universally accepted.
Like cricket protein,
protein bars.
You don't see too many other insects
being like commercially harvested.
David and I were in New York,
uh,
for Anthony's a memory thing,
memorial thing and we walked in the
bowery and you know,
middle of the afternoon,
Hudson,
oh,
this is a good meal and there's like a
little store,
no refrigeration and there's buckets of
clams and you know,
like Mesh bags,
like you put onions in his big mesh bag
in the bin and it's full of giant bull
frogs.
Like looking up at it like a hundred
little bullfrog,
but like it's like oranges and a box,
like one,
two,
three,
four,
five live in their little lies.
Just looking up like this.
And I was like,
sure we have frogs in the book,
but that was.
So hang on,
fred and I had been cooking for years,
like,
you know,
25 years arguably if not more,
I've probably assessed were processed or
a French cookie.
Okay.
So of course we can.
We just look at the frogs.
We don't say anything to each other.
We keep on walking and I go,
hang on a sec,
fred,
walk me through.
This goes,
how exactly does this work?
I know how to do a rabbit.
I know how to do a hair.
I know how to do a duck.
I know how to do any fish.
Any seafood.
Lobster.
Case of frog in the kitchen.
What's your first move right now?
What's their first move?
So we take the live frog.
Do I put it on the cutting board?
Do I hack its legs off and what do I do
with the 60 percent remaining of the
frog?
Yeah.
Is it,
is it ground?
Does it end up in dumplings?
Where's that other part of the frog
going?
Is it soup?
Is it broth?
Know that's an amphibian.
It was fascinating.
Did you experiment?
No,
I'm mortified.
And after that we went to Tony's
memorial.
It was a Chinese restaurant and I was
just like,
I couldn't eat because by default
everything had like frog in it in my
head.
So you were freaking out just because
they were alive staring up at you know,
because I know that the legs are
delicious.
I know that,
you know,
if I chop the legs off and I peel the
skin and I dredge them in flour and I
fry them and I served them with garlic
cream,
that they're delicious.
There's delicious chicken wings.
What I'm worried about is the frog is so
big and you know,
the discarded part of the frog is a size
of a softball.
Right.
So yeah.
It's like eating the stem of the apple
and leaving the apple in cooking.
We don't throw stuff out.
Right,
right.
So I want to know what happens to that
part in Chinese cookery or French
cookery?
Well,
the place that you guys were at was a
Chinese market.
Yeah,
it was one of those hole in the door,
kind of like supplier and it was like we
got it.
There were claims that were wink Perry
winkles.
There were like all like Google never
processed trogs in my career.
Really,
you know,
when I've gotten fresh frogs,
I was working in France and it was just
the frog's legs and a button in a
basket.
But even then I would wonder in France,
where does that other part go?
I know this is a very disturbing,
what seems like there's got to be an
answer to this.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It would be the people that I would call
one ton stuffing.
Right?
Sort of boiled and I'm hoping they're
discarded.
I just googled it and the video is a
graphic.
Let it go.
Let it roll.
I can't,
I'm not going to put it up on Youtube.
Okay.
We'll put it up.
Put it up for us so we can see it.
Here we go.
Okay.
Oh No.
They don't even bother killing them
first.
They just do it on the fly.
So the legs off off.
That's exactly how I pursue ease.
Okay.
So they squeeze it out once,
cut the head off the.
They squeeze it out like A.
Would you describe that?
Like they're appealing it now.
Right?
So then they squeezed the,
they squeezed the innards out through
the neck cavity.
The last of toothpaste.
Yes.
That's a good way to describe it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So then they take it.
Now it looks like a man because it's
headless.
It's like a headless man that's.
It's like one of those you use to draw
bodies there?
Yeah,
I would,
I would.
I would point you put the batteries to
the hind legs.
Batteries know in like high school.
Oh,
right.
You put the little battery in the back.
Light cigarettes in them.
He's chopping them up.
It seems like he's leaving the bones on.
Is that what he's doing?
Yeah.
Okay.
So you know what,
it's really great that we're watching
this because I'm a lot less horrified by
the whole prospect of it.
So he's just hacking it up.
Bones intact and then.
And chucking it into a basket so it
doesn't look like they're missing much
other than the guts.
So it seems like the energy and then
they seem to be boiling all that stuff
and okay.
So they put it in a soup with the bones
and tact and you just sort of
highlighted that it.
Yeah.
It's funny.
If I had to make a dish with data and
make the super daily lives inside the
water lilies,
I mean with lily pad soup with frog.
What is.
Have you ever tried anything with no
leaves?
Look like lily pads,
right?
Those are hot right now and cooking.
Do you guys try to do that,
like add some of the ingredients of the
native environments of the tricks to
cooking?
What are the best tricks or cooking?
When you chef told me this a long time
ago in France,
he goes,
well,
chef,
what should I cook with a lamb with?
He goes cheesy.
What would it eat if you had a land?
What would be growing around it and it
automatically.
You just scroll down.
If I had a lamb and a p,
an acre of land,
what would be around it?
There would be turnips,
there would be carrots and onions.
There will be apples,
there'll be pairs,
there will be time,
there will be basil,
there would be garlic,
there would be.
So just.
There you go.
Traditional idealic environment.
Yeah.
The problem is is when you have lobster
and you cook it with mangoes,
right?
We're lobster is where law comes from.
There's no mangoes,
so the recipe doesn't make sense.
Might be delicious,
but it's dumb.
But butter,
lobster and butter,
they go together.
Lobster,
butter,
potatoes.
What else grows their onions?
A Prince Edward Island.
Okay.
Small island in the Gulf.
One of the provinces of Canada.
We have cows.
So you'd say those and lobster.
Three resources.
Not the.
Not the actual environment.
A rabbit.
If you have a rabbit in your backyard or
you know,
in the line of sight.
Right.
I get what can you see there?
Oh,
rabbit with apples and carrots.
Makes Sense.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But.
But what if lobster and mango is fucking
delicious?
Yeah.
But then,
uh,
you know,
for other people to do,
we have our principals academically
incorrect.
Incorrect.
That's fascinating.
One of my favorite pizzas.
Don't get disgusted at me.
Don't hate me.
Pineapple and Ancho.
Pineapple and anchovy.
That's right.
Pineapple and ham and pineapple and
anchovy.
It's God damn delicious.
I fucking love it.
I don't care what you say.
Who does that though?
You'd invented that.
I might have.
That's good.
Now I want to try it.
I want to try frog soup with lily pads
and pineapple and anchovy pizza with
both.
Part with the pineapple and hard with
the anchovy.
Do you want to write a book?
Three with us,
with Joe.
I'm good at elk steaks and I know how to
order pineapple and anchovy pizza.
I have to say that when they see your
picture you posted if you're a meat
cooking.
Not Bad.
It's always on point.
Thank you very much.
Because there's a lot of hunters that
post up pictures of their dinner and
it's not because like you can take
pictures and they'll look beautiful with
like a vanity thing.
It's not the quality of the picture but
the food is a little bit.
Yeah.
Some hunters don't know how to cook.
We have a lot of hunters in Quebec and
sometimes you know the hunter will bring
by the.
Because I shot this beautiful Mousse
David at wayside 2000 pounds or 1500
pounds and he shows me a picture on his
phone and then he brings me a jar of the
spaghetti sauce he made out of the Moose
after like really like you.
You shot them majestic Moose and the
forest and you made spaghetti sauce with
it.
Like put Kiwi and then because it
tenderizes the meat.
Well listen,
spaghetti sauce with ground moves is
delicious.
I'll give you a tip.
You gotta have you gotta have a high eat
everything.
I eat the whole thing,
right?
I mean I,
I've,
I know how to make the roasts and I use
the ground for a bunch of different
things and I just think that if you,
if you do it properly or if you,
if you want to handle it properly,
you've really got to read up on how to
cook wild game as opposed to how to cook
anything else.
There's a very little fat content.
It's a tricky kind of meat to cook.
There's a tool,
it's called a lapdog in French.
It's like a big needle with a swivel tip
and what you do is you cut long strips
of fat and you poke him through the
meat,
abject it.
Yet you don't inject,
you put like,
like writing it,
threading your piece of meat,
like the loins are the fat,
the back straps,
it's,
it tends to be leaner.
So you put long strips of pork fat
inside and you cook it slowly enough
that the pork fat will melt inside.
So in every bite you'll have a little
bit of fat to neat saying it's an old
French cooking treg yeah,
that sounds sensational.
Or what we do actually for the wild
rabbit,
which is extremely dry,
we'll put a veal foot with the skin,
so that'll give up the Collagen and
we'll put the slice of pork belly with
it.
They'll give up the fat.
When are you guys going back to
Montreal?
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow?
Yeah.
I can't give you meat,
right?
It wouldn't.
No,
it couldn't get through.
The border.
Wouldn't work this way.
The other way works.
Yes,
it works if you
hunted and bringing it through.
I brought.
I brought me back,
but a damn.
I'd like to give you guys something.
See what you do with it.
It's a lot of things.
It's our favorite meat,
but you know,
it would be sooner.
Be caught with bricks of hashish then.
Then Venison as restaurant owners,
you know,
like,
like you,
we'd been.
You cannot have any wild game in your
restaurant.
Even if it's just for your own personal
consumption,
not really started yet into two is a
problem and never in Quebec if caviar,
you know,
we have a lot of sturgeon in the Gulf of
St Lawrence that laws are written like
lights out,
ridiculous.
If you get caught with like a gram of
caviar and your boat,
you don't have a license,
so freeze your bank accounts and sees
your house kind of thing and we'd go and
we'd go south quick.
What is the concern?
Is it such a commercial market for
sturgeon caviar?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Wow.
So people will just go that far out of
their way to get caviar that they had to
just make these.
It's like a fish right now is worthless
if you can't use the caviar.
Right.
We're allowed that.
There's a fishery for them.
They fished sturgeon in the Gulf of St
Lawrence.
When they catch them,
they have to gut them.
They have to remove every egg and dump
the eggs into the water that they're
allowed to bring the meat back,
to smoke it and salt it and to sell it.
There is a commercial commercial wild
fishery for a sturgeon meat,
but the.
So ultimately you just put a price tag
on the fish.
Let's say it's worth 200 bucks,
but all of a sudden if you're allowed to
harvest the eggs and the fish,
15 grand.
Yeah,
it would just be,
yeah,
because they produce a more monolithic
amount of eggs.
What's crazy is now you're making it
useless because you're throwing it away.
Something that's incredibly valuable and
delicious.
The quotas are very small though.
Let's say if you had a sturgeon license,
I imagine you're allowed five or six or
something like that.
And uh,
the first nations like Mohawks,
the heroes have the right to fish.
You know,
we've been on boats where a guy was
fishing,
you know,
he showed us the traditional technique
and it's not the sports fishing like the
soup,
they,
this,
they like,
they love it.
It's great fish in themselves.
They the eggs and make soup.
They put the eggs in it they like or
they catch sergeant 20 minutes from Joe
Beef right there downtown.
It's a dinosaur.
It would up with a spear.
Wow.
It's a crazy animal.
And when you see them in the water,
yeah.
Do you see the scales on them?
So bizarre that I mean,
how they're from what 100 million years
ago to start.
Once they look like dinosaurs,
they really do.
And the guys that we know that the
system is quite the character is an
interesting guy.
He's a,
he's a Mohawk and he told us that the
biologist but underwater cameras there
to look,
keep track of the fish and they said
they see like 16 layers of sturgeon
swimming,
one at the top of the other.
He said I could walk on the fish.
You know,
there's that many.
Yeah,
there's a ton.
Wow.
That's.
But again,
you know,
the people don't really.
We even struggled with it at the
restaurant.
For me to sell a plate of smoked
sturgeon,
tough sell,
you know,
sooner sell other things than that.
Uh,
people aren't interested.
I think it's a tough sell as a fish.
Let's say as a,
as a 200 gram or four ounce piece of
fish thing.
That is so crazy.
Is that the same river?
That's probably Columbia river sturgeon.
That looks like frasier.
Yeah.
Fraser,
NBC.
Look at the size of that thing.
That is so ancient looking.
It looks like it shouldn't be here.
Yeah,
it's a fish that's a bit muddy.
Do sometimes depending on where it's
caught and everything.
So how do you,
uh,
how do you handle it?
Like if you were going to cook one of
those,
we make Jamaican patties.
Fuck,
we did an old French cookery.
Uh,
one of the ways to cook sturgeon is,
you know,
ultimately you apply cooking a piece of
sturgeon loin as you would a piece of
veal loin of pork loin.
A meat juice even is acceptable,
you know,
roasted carrots,
roasted onions,
roasted to salary,
roast the storage in and bake bacon,
mushroom red wine,
like Fred said.
So you treat the sturgeon as you would
meet is possibly the best way to treat
it as you would.
Fish is not the best.
You know,
people got to expect we were overly
fortunate to have,
you know,
300 gram,
like a pound of fish,
seared in a pan and served with a little
sauce was common thing.
Right.
But it's not the right thing to do if we
want to keep things in the water,
you know,
for kids or whatever.
So people got used to this like a piece
of fish that they like,
nothing that you can eat for like an
hour and a half because you have so much
of it then that's the standard.
But at fish lake sturgeon is great.
If you have a little bit then the sauce,
like David Mate says,
talks about over like a buttery mashed
potatoes or like with like an egg
noodles or something like that.
It's a great way to do it.
Then it's a great way to look at fish
were like,
you need actually 75 grams of protein,
not like 500.
What is the,
is there a comparison that you can make
in terms of what it tastes like?
Yeah,
I'm [inaudible] a little bit,
I guess somewhat braised a braised veal
color.
Uh,
what'd you say?
Blanquette?
I'd do a larger piece of stew,
like not a small two inch block of Stew,
but let's say a bigger piece of stew
with a chunk of seaweed in it,
you know?
Yeah,
it's neat.
It's neat.
It sounds now I'm hungry for it.
We do like a fred.
Fred got the,
made the God,
the big nuggets.
Molds,
you know,
because you know,
the mcnuggets have this like not there
was like four or five different sizes.
Fred made the mold and the first book I,
they precisely exactly like the
Mcdonald's mcnuggets and we used to do
sturgeon mcnuggets or eel eel mcnuggets.
Same fishery,
right?
We have deals where we get sturgeon.
Uh,
it was kind of a ton of them at the
restaurant.
It would literally,
you'd be a job for and you'd get on your
plate what looked to be like six
mcnuggets with the sauce and the Little
Paper Cup on the side.
People like,
what the hell is this?
I says,
Sergeant Nuggets.
People is a weird one.
When I used to go fishing,
a lot of people would catch eels,
they'd be upset,
like,
and then I would go to buy Sushi later
on in life and uh,
there'd be eel Sushi and I'd be like,
what the fuck is going on different?
A Wolf Wolf Eel.
It's a different fence.
It's not,
it's not a true isla in Sushi.
Yeah,
correct.
Yeah.
Even like the real deal,
I'm,
I can eat bits of it,
but if we were to take a kneel eel and
dislike first you have to put a nail in
his head and the nail and it's Dale and
like skin it and cut its head off and
peel it and put it in a cast iron pan
with butter.
And it's still moving like a snake and
the smell of it,
it makes you choke,
you know,
we had like four.
We had a little truck pond at Joe beef
that I built,
you know,
really that and it,
it was a bad experience because we had a
refrigerator thing that makes the water
cold,
you know,
a cooler.
And we had a pump.
Every time it rained,
it would turn the breaker off and now
the fish like drowned,
drowned,
no oxygen.
Martin Picard gave us some meals and we
found him the next day in the parking
lot,
like all the way on the other side of
the parking lot and the baseball field
or the bleachers when shit,
they're cooking it and it's swimming at
a head and no skin at this point.
This is a grill.
What does it say?
It say shocking clip of cooking and eel
alive in Seoul.
Nobody's got that.
That els beheaded and skinned beheaded.
Still nervous system is still very
intact.
What is,
what are those things?
In the bottom there was this legs.
What is.
That's probably its guts.
Oh God.
Look at that thing bucket,
man.
That's like,
that's real.
Stir frying.
I caught one whites in Nova Scotia and a
hook and line and when I caught it,
the fisherman next to me,
he said,
oh,
don't reel it in.
So I just held my fishing rod.
I wasn't reading in and the eel real.
That itself up my line to the tip of my
fishing rod and started reading down my
fishing rod towards me.
I was a kid.
I was horrified.
Ever since then I've had an issue with
like I worked in a restaurant in France
and diesel and in the fridge right near
the cook of the hotline,
the cooking line.
There was a wooden box with a
cinderblock on it.
It's the first day at work there.
I was helping out on the fish station
and I hear in French [inaudible] on come
on the Webinar,
what do you all ordered up?
And then the,
the,
the fish chef says go in the fridge,
there's a wooden box.
You take the cinder block off it,
you just lift the lid a little bit.
Plunger hand in there,
grabbing eel and bring it back to me.
I was like,
kidding,
right.
So I literally do that.
Go into the walk in fridge.
I pulled a wooden box out,
I take the cinder block off the top,
I lift the hit.
It was just literally,
you know,
50 eels rising together and it's like
Indiana Jones,
you know,
they live with an out of water.
No problem.
Martin Picard at Peter Shaw in his
restaurant right now.
What was there last week?
He has a lobster tank right in the
doorway.
I think they hang your coats right above
it and in it there's like eight massive
eels.
Then chase them when they come at work
in the morning they reopened the
restaurant.
They'll find them like in the cash,
register it in the coat check.
They have like cinderblocks down now on
the top they got a plexi glass top with
holes in it,
so it oxygenates and they're like
literally pinned down in that tank.
But even as you're eating and you just
see those giant eels in the tank or size
of your flag here,
it's just horrific.
You know,
it's the best thing about eels talking
about it.
Now.
What about the flavor?
I like it.
Super smoked,
super salted down with a good sugary,
salty brine.
You have to cover it like in nuggets
like we did,
but like even like laying dead
restaurant David was talking about if
you take a fresh piece of veal and put
it in a cast iron pan to smoke,
it does.
It's like mustard gas.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's good.
Like it's super.
I'm a little bit allergic to it.
I guess not all fish but some fish and
I,
when I used to work at that restaurant,
we would literally like put a knife
through his head and into the cutting
board and then another knife through its
tail so it would be straight on the,
on the cutting boards.
We pinned down the left side on the
right side of the hill.
Then we'd lift the filets skin them,
score them,
and then Pan sear them with artichoke
and country ham.
And as I was pants hearing them,
I was breathing in the vapors of searing
the eel and my,
my lungs would seize,
you know,
I'd have like kind of like,
it would give me an asthma attack
somewhat.
It was wild.
Now it's just a popular dish in France
because of necessity,
because of a lack of,
a lot of,
a lot of old French cooking would be
based on what you had in your
neighborhood.
Uh,
you know,
French cooking was very different pre
federal express,
pre roads,
you know,
so eels in French cooking would come
from the Bordeaux region ultimately,
and you know,
it would be like a donkey,
so it would be an eel stu in red wine of
course,
carrot,
onion,
celery.
Exactly like a beef stew.
And I think also the thing about it is
that it's a dish that you wouldn't make
at home,
you know,
so people would go,
lay on d,
Let's go need to heal because that's
what there was.
You don't want to have the cinderblock
plexiglass case in your house.
And then the imagine your house with
your,
your kids are my kids land praise,
there's Bordeaux,
there's some,
you know,
some of the famous iconic dishes of
Bordeaux is lamb praise.
This is like an animal from Dune,
you know,
it's like a big hole with teeth.
They're the ones that cling to the
bottom of sharks.
Correct,
no,
that's a remora.
Oh,
okay.
The land prey is a problem actually.
Now,
even in America,
they're coming up in some rivers and
they attached themselves to fish with
their suction cup head.
They're just horrific animal suction cup
head too.
If it's like,
dude,
it's like that alimony dude look like
that.
Yeah.
What do they taste like?
Probably the crappy like eel.
We did a dinner Shittier Isla.
We did a dinner for Tony when he did his
second book I think at Liverpool House
and I was,
we were much younger and I was like,
oh,
let's buy some like daring food,
you know,
Tony Board endless by something like
fucked up.
So I ordered like two of those eel and I
try to make soup.
Widowhood had tried to make everything
and again,
you know,
the classic Joe,
the best thing to do it is to put it in
the garbage.
You are,
you make stock,
you reduce it.
The nutro it away.
I'm sure there's a recipe that's good
and I'm sure in,
in case of apocalypse after the winter
succeeds will fish for that and we'll
eat it.
But until then,
I'm,
I'm okay with like cutting my big MACs
in half,
so they last for two days.
He was a cool company that I've been
following a company online I think on
twitter,
instagram.
It's called American who Nagi.
They're up in the Atlantic,
northeast area I think in Maine or
Massachusetts somewhere or they have
some really.
They're raising eels,
I think releasing them into the nature
and they're selling eels commercially.
They looks again like horrific work
raising them and releasing them in the
field.
Who is there like some sort of a
environmental benefit of having the
eels?
Is it staying about the lobster and put
it away in a freshwater river?
There are weird animal.
Right?
Again,
loosely based.
My facts are old reading,
but from what I recall,
eels are cool because they all the eels
every year.
Go back to the Sargasso Sea.
Is it true that that's what I remember.
Was that folklore,
you think?
Filtration,
volume?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oysters,
filter emails.
So they all go back to this one area
though.
Supposedly there's a breeding area for
them called the Sargasso Sea.
Great place for swimming.
And where's the Sargasso sea is kind of
a southern Middle Atlantic from what I
recall.
So that's pretty.
That's pretty safe,
right?
Where the where the where.
The mythical plastic patches.
Oh,
the plastic.
That's a pacific.
You think that's mythical?
I Dunno.
I've never seen really a giant,
a real true picture of the Sargasso Sea.
The eels in our last date in their way.
Wow.
That's so creepy.
Look at that fucker making his way.
Beautiful.
Video two.
And what is pretty cool?
Wow.
This is a guy named boy slot.
This is name,
who is a young fellow that figured out a
way to filter out the garbage patch and
he has been.
He developed this device and they
recently started implementing it,
but he's been uh,
he's been on the podcast before and when
a great detail about it,
the garbage patch is real.
The American Pie.
Whoa.
Look at those fuckers just flopping
around.
Yeah.
So they're an American new Nike's a
instagram page we're on right now.
They're in Maine.
Yeah.
Our aquaculture.
That's cool.
Demaris Kata is great.
Oysters there too.
What about,
have you guys ever cooked or eaten?
Blueberry bear.
No,
we don't Mark Marta in Montreal.
Martinez even embarrassed.
He's hunting berry goes and baits every
weekend and then he goes in shacks.
And what's a blueberry bear though?
My friend Steve Rinella.
It's described this to
apparently when bears eat blueberries,
when they find like it's towards the
fall in particular when the trend of
fatten up before they go into the den,
they'll find these massive fields of
blueberries.
He,
he shot one in Alaska and this bear had
eaten so many blueberries and when they
opened it up it smelled like
blueberries.
The,
the actual fat had a purple hue to it
and it's supposed to be as spectacularly
delicious meat.
Totally makes sense.
But you know that.
It's funny you say that because I was
thinking about that with Venice and
before we have some friends who had a
venison from and what would they visit?
Right?
This is steve cooking it on the show
shows called mediator will actually a
guest on the show here Friday.
Um,
but see how the fat tissue to it.
But he said it's,
it all smells like blueberry.
So he rendered down the bear fat and
then because this was all in the field
and then cook the bear meat is blueberry
bear meat chunks of it in the fat.
Well,
if the pigment is a lipid soluble,
then it would make sense that you find
it in the fat.
But they made a,
they made experiments,
are friends with the deer farm and what
they did,
they wanted to know if the,
the taste of venison was owed to the
fact that the diet of the animal or the
way that hunters traditionally break
down the meat in the field,
the field dressing of the meat,
you know.
So what they did is they put up a beef,
like a steer and they shot him and they,
they prepared them,
they dressed him the way you would a
deer or a moose and then they at the
same time did the same thing with the
deer.
And then they did the slaughterhouse
treatment like a commercial treatment
for both animal.
And they realize that once you,
um,
your weight a little bit,
even on the beef before you got it,
before you skin it and everything that
funky or that Gamey taste will come even
to beef no fracture.
That's why yeast in nature,
it's probably also they think that you
might like the skills to properly
extract the guts.
You might perforate the guts sometime.
You might perforate the,
the bile a pouch there.
Parts of the innards might come in
contact with the skin will be onto long,
not bled properly as well.
Yeah.
It's not blend properly.
And then,
you know,
it's not chilled super rapidly.
Make you kill in the morning.
The whole sun is out,
you know,
you don't have a fridge with you.
We have no water.
And.
But on the other hand,
when we have the wild rabbits,
they taste like juniper,
like very,
very,
very strongly like juniper.
And that's,
that's in fact the challenge is to get
rid of some of that juniper taste.
It's like the partridge that we shoot at
the lake and in fact it's spruce spruce
tips and instead of when we cook,
sometimes we'll cook meat and then
we'll,
we'll even add a partridge or at home
I'll have the partridge or a wild rabbit
just as seasoning to the rest of the
pot.
You know,
if you look at all the traditional
French Canadian dishes of hunters,
they're all like all the games that are
mixed up,
you know,
so you never have.
This is a modern queasy ne like culinary
fancy thing to have a breast of
partridge seared on a bed of cabbage.
You know,
those things are always treated with,
like I said earlier,
with fat,
with like all the spices,
with wine,
with Cognac,
with layers of like,
you know,
even like organ meats in there and you
put a crust over eighth and cabbage,
you know,
it's like,
that's like we said,
it needs a lot of skills to eat.
Like good game.
Yeah.
I've never had gamey venison.
I've been very,
very fortunate that I've.
First of all,
I've learned to hunt from people that
really know what they're doing.
So we didn't let anything sit out in the
heat and made sure we opened it up and
cooled it out quickly,
but one of the things that they do do
when guys are deep into the back country
and they have an animal and they kill it
and it's even in the summer when it's
warm out,
what they do is they hang it and give it
a lot of air circulation.
It develops a crust on the outside and
then they cut that cross back.
Um,
and then the meat underneath it is sort
of tenderized and a lot of ways in a lot
of hunters say that it's even more
delicious that way.
It's protected by the,
by the,
by the crusty created.
Of course it probably starts.
The bacteriological work starts to work
inside of that crust.
There's age
to process by which the meat gets
standard.
The first one is the rigor Mortis,
right?
Like the meat rests and the rigor
mortis.
I guess all the cortisol and everything
that like stiffens the meat at death.
Well,
the meat will rest and then it's an
enzymatic reaction where the enzymes,
where it can break some of the meat
fibers and the tougher muscles and stuff
in French.
The word for arresting meet this called
[inaudible] on d and fasten is a
pheasant,
you know,
because they used to hang the pheasants
by the neck until they fell.
Falls off the skull.
Then they're ready to eat.
Yeah,
I've seen that before.
That is so strange.
It's hard to eat.
I've had it a couple of times when
people like this,
it tastes like death warmed over.
What the fuck is wrong with these
people?
Why are they eating it?
Like guys,
it's a,
you know,
a lot people love a strong flavors like
blue cheese,
like munster cheese in Germany.
Uh,
you know,
so this is all because ultimately if you
just eat it fresh,
it's chicken of the woods really.
Right.
So it's good.
Yeah.
By letting it go a little bit,
letting it ride a little bit.
They get these like secondary,
tertiary,
intense flavors though
maybe two or talking about probiotics.
You don't those traditional ways.
You don't always know what you,
why you do them,
but maybe initially they're like you
incubate the know,
you immunize yourself a little bit,
you know,
like the taste is,
you got to love it after you're used to
it,
but initially it might be a way to have
some of the bacteria is.
I think you talked about soil based
probiotics before I read about that,
like we're realizing that like okay,
yogurt,
probiotics are not the whole thing,
you know,
so maybe there's soil based probiotic,
animal based probiotic maybe were
completely wrong about what flora we're
ingesting and maybe there was like a way
to get your flora.
Yeah,
makes sense.
I guess there would be some strategies
for taking that stuff in,
but I would think flavor wise it would
mean cause pheasant if you just eat it
fresh.
It's delicious.
It's light.
It's very nice.
Like I would think that
unless there was no other way to store
it and they didn't have refrigeration,
which of course they didn't when they
first start.
Refrigeration is a super modern
invention.
If you look back,
like I worked for chefs in my
apprenticeship that told me stories
about their apprenticeship and it's like
night and day,
they said when we woke up in the
morning,
we used to have to fill the ovens with
coal,
you know,
and go down to the Ice Locker and dragon
ice block into through the,
what's that stuff called?
The Wood Sawdust,
this sawdust shed.
And I was like,
what?
Wow,
you know,
is that a lot of these old French
restaurants that are famous had coal
fired ovens and ice block fridges
and the apprentices would live above and
they take shifts.
You know,
one night they'd be you that would make
sure it doesn't die because otherwise
it'd be hard to start again,
you know,
like burn every day.
All of it,
all the time.
The restaurant stove was ultimately,
it was also heating the whole building
as well.
The hotel was heated by the wow,
but makes sense.
I mean,
it really does,
but there's not a lot of animals that
they would let it get that funky other
than shark.
The shark.
Oh,
they're doing the Iceland or a shark.
There's a Korean dish that I'm actually
curious to try,
it's Cape Wing that is fermented,
but until it gets that ammonia flavor,
you know,
like you smell a camel bear and they
pause and you smell it,
smells good,
funky cheese.
Then you go a bit deeper,
you know,
bigger width.
And then we were like windex,
you know,
you got the ammonia.
Some people look for that different
cultures or into different flavors is a
friend of my nandy went to Calcutta
three weeks ago and came back with the
number one candy in Calcutta or in
India.
It's just weird candy called pulse.
If we had one right now,
all three of us.
It's a repulsive candy that tastes
incredibly of sulfur and fecal rot.
But in,
in India,
that's the candy.
Like people love it.
You know,
in American winemaking and French
winemaking,
there's things in winemaking called
flaws,
the flaws of wine in France and in
natural winemaking,
organic winemaking will always be
volatile.
Acidity and Bertino miceys,
um,
volatile acidity smells in the wine
vastly of vinegar.
And Bertetto miceys smells vastly of
fecal matter.
Barnyard fecal matter,
you know,
uh,
these in,
in,
in North American wine and even in
French wine are considered as flaws.
You know,
in Japan,
they love natural wines from France that
have high volatile acidity and
brettanomyces smells what would be
ultimately considered a flawed wine.
And France and natural wine world is
considered a delicacy in Japan and the
natural wine world.
Wow.
So do they purposely take ones that have
that funky smell and ship them off to
Japan?
Some winemakers,
the line agent will come and visit the
seller and usually the winemaker will
point him in the direction and say,
maybe this might be for you guys.
Yes,
yes.
This is what we like.
We'll take cultivated on purpose and
that I figure like a,
nobody right now will come up and say it
outright.
Uh,
but I believe so as Japanese there are
Japanese winemakers now all through
France that work in a very funky way and
are more or less,
you know,
pushing those wines into the Japanese
market.
Okay.
I have to try this just because it's
disgusting.
So tell me what the name of the candy is
again.
Pulse misspelled that put you lsc.
It's a green mango candy.
Yeah,
it's originally,
it's a classic snuck right where they
use the sulfur salt.
It's called black salt and they'd put a
bit of Chili and sulfur salt on mango
and I have to admit that when I had
the real green mango with the sulfur
salt is not that bad.
That candy was like pushed.
It's like the mega warheads,
you know,
that we had as kids.
I wonder too sometimes the Gamey flavor
of the cheese.
That is the yield of that is I see it
sometimes as a bit of a like,
you know,
the ghost peppers,
a bit of a pissing contest between,
you know,
like it's like no one could possibly
enjoy the taste of gross prep.
No,
no.
I mean,
does it even have a taste?
you even responding to that taste.
I won't even try it.
Who,
you know,
who loves that,
alleviate those guys.
They have like,
they watch like game of thrones,
they get together and they,
those peppers.
Oh yeah.
They have like Olivier all Boman mercier
who's a fighter in the UFC and they'll,
they'll have like ghost pepper parties,
you know,
and then the next day they'll go to
comicon and dress up as superheroes and
then place them online poker and then
eat more ghost peppers.
He's also a UFC fighter.
You got to think he's a very extreme
human being.
He's a funny kid,
but he's very,
very,
very nice guy.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
No,
that,
he was a trained killer.
You would have no idea if you talked to
them.
It just seems like a gentleman.
He's a sweetie.
He's a good kid and it's a good fit for
us.
It's interesting.
You know,
we,
we actually have a bit of a chapter in
the book where we talk loosely about
those guys in that relationship where
you guys sponsored him or something
before the reebok thing.
Yeah.
Because I remember one of the fights
that we did in Montreal,
we went to your restaurant afterwards
and Olivier showed up after his fight
and you guys were congratulating him and
his,
uh,
his fiance's,
his wife works,
his girlfriend works with us at the
restaurant for a long time now.
And uh,
you know,
we met because these guys,
it's interesting,
they're super into food and they're open
to a lot of things and they're curious
and a lot of them get aimed in the wrong
direction,
you know,
like the brown rice and chicken
direction and,
and you're responsible for in big part
for the awakening,
the nutritional awakening of these guys,
you know,
a lot of them go for their gun license
now just to be able to hunt.
They go fishing on the weekend,
they go for like two hours hike in the
woods and like little fishing rod.
They come back with droughts and we get
a phone call.
He's like,
Hey Fred,
I go fish for trout.
You know,
what do I do with that?
it's,
it's a great thing.
And Yeah,
we did,
we did sponsor them after.
But then what we do now is we,
um,
we cook for them post way in A.
Marco did GSP the last fight at Madison
Square Gardens.
They were,
the boys were there for a week.
We've done Tim Kennedy after for a week
and just hung out and cooked meals.
We sat in the kids a Marco and Fred goes
and Gab goes,
Gabrielle drop pro.
They go,
they rent a suite and they prepare all
of the
up to weight cut and afterwards and do
they have nutritional requirements for
the weight cut and like the week they
do,
they have a nutritionist there with
them,
but then they had lines.
But my,
I have a take on that is if the
nutritionist writes a plan and the
food's not good and you don't eat it,
then it doesn't.
Doesn't work,
right?
Like Amoeba,
right on paper.
But if you don't take the pill then you,
you don't just say chicken and Kale,
this much grams this.
But we can.
Professional Cook will make the Kale
delicious or Brussels Brian's chicken
properly because the Kale could be bad
and the chicken and be dry thing too.
That works,
that are already suffering.
The thing that works the best in that
case is that all of a sudden you have in
the room,
we set up a little table which is so.
It's not like playstation dirty,
underwears,
pre-fight vibe.
It's dining with friends,
it's dining with friends and whether
it's Marco Gab me,
we know we don't talk.
If you don't want to talk,
you want to talk.
We're here,
you know,
and we'll,
we'll,
we'll hang out.
But then you feel like your eggs in that
Tortilla,
you feel like your eggs with potatoes or
like it's mellow and it helps a lot with
the,
just the context of not being like
ordering pizza from room service.
You know,
Jordan used to tell us all horror
stories.
We know before some of his biggest wins
years ago with George say eating like
room service Rigatoni and pizza before
like a major fight.
You know.
So now it's different and it's fun
because like David said earlier,
we have many interests and it's great to
be able to explore them like that.
You know,
because we couldn't,
we couldn't do this job if it was for
like 12 stoves in the kitchen,
a bunch of pans,
cooking pieces of meat,
writing books about the seasons and
tomatoes and starting again.
Like I,
I couldn't do it.
Like we love that being a chef.
It's like one dimensional really,
you know?
And that whether it's like Olivia with
it,
it's like going to visit and Neil farm
and you know,
like it's,
it's,
it's makes it worthwhile up to this
point.
Well you guys have a great philosophy
about that and that's one of the things
that really came through with the board
danger when you guys were in the ice
shack,
is that you,
you enjoy living well.
Yeah.
Everybody has to live better.
Take care of yourself matter.
Get Out,
turn your phone off,
sit with your kids,
listen to brilliant things,
man.
Mind your phone off and come with
stories.
I had friends,
one of my.
I have all my children now.
I'd,
I'd love to sit at the table and I'm
quiet.
I just let them talk and asked me
questions and watch them and it's just
the best.
It's better than my relationship.
My kids is better than any relationship
I have with any of my best friends.
My kids are more interesting,
my family's more interesting and it's
work to stay in
contact with your family and even the
staff,
you know?
Uh,
I enjoy very much working in the
restaurants that we've built.
Um,
some I work five days a week with people
that I've been working with for 15
years.
These are important relationships.
It's not employee employer.
It's if you quit and you to tell me
you're leaving.
I want to be.
I'm going to go my car and cry.
I've been working with you for 15 years.
My relationship that I have with many
people that I work with is intimate.
I've seen their children born.
I've seen them go through breakups.
I've seen them.
Their parents die.
I've seen,
you know,
like we go to war every night at 6:00,
150 people are coming to eat in the next
three hours in for restaurants.
We,
you know,
it's a job that's so different than high
stress environment for five minutes,
for two hours.
It's,
we've got to walk properly.
We got to where we were knowledgeable of
each other's space.
So there's a ballet,
you know,
when you're washing the glasses and the
food's coming up behind you,
you know,
you have this sixth sense to know,
to move,
not to get the plate,
to burn your elbow and you know,
this ballet,
we dance every night with these people
and for us to think that like in most
people's,
to still think that we're behind the
stove cooking.
I've got more phone calls to get help
finding a doctor,
therapist,
whatever,
you know,
nutrition is for the staff.
Then I got calls about recipes or food
or you know,
our job is,
I'm an expert in drainpipes,
artisinal plumbing,
artisinal,
electricity,
refrigeration.
I know about boring now because you've
done it yourself like Sarah very
decrepit old buildings and you can't,
you know,
we're running a restaurants with
employees and a constant burden of
payroll and we can't just call everybody
all the time to just so you know,
by default any good cooking school
today,
but what Fred is saying,
and Fred is the example of what a great
chef should be,
be a very good cook,
a very good person with people's skills,
but should also have a minor and
electricity,
plumbing and refrigeration technologies
stayed.
You know,
even even now,
like we both,
we both don't drink both.
I wouldn't say a health kick butt,
just like wouldn't be there.
You know,
my mind and body,
we want to be like president and that's,
that's we build something cool.
I want to appreciate it.
Not Be clouded.
Overlook that.
That's that.
Like people don't think about that when
they get into this job,
you know,
they,
they think it's this warrior thing,
this were savage.
We're going to drink,
we're going to party,
we're going to do this.
If you want to do that till you're 60
and then get a little cottage and right
paint,
water color,
buy but buy a sailboat.
You have to think about it.
You know,
it's like you can't live that life of
drinking.
And why do you think that life is
synonymous with chefs?
We've been promoted and taught
ultimately that you will get paid.
You will make money,
you will persevere.
If you understand how to promote
excessive eating and excessive drinking,
you will be recompensed.
If you build a place where people come
and eat too much and drink too much and
that spend too much,
then you will be able to have a life,
a car,
a house,
and raise children.
Okay,
so it's all good.
First you have to learn how to cook.
Then you have to learn how to run a
restaurant.
Then you have to learn how to,
what a restaurant looks like and how to
run and you know how to host,
how to host,
what the playlist should be like,
a how to fix a plumbing disaster,
how to fix the electricity,
the disaster,
how to fix a staff situation.
Disaster.
How to run a clean house or people are
working together with all their
different idiosyncrasies.
But for my whole apprenticeship,
alcohol was a reward.
You know,
uh,
you did a good job tonight.
Drink,
you know.
Then it went from reward.
Do.
Oh Shit.
That was like a blood bath in the
restaurant.
You know,
we had to pick up this guy at the
hospital.
Okay,
it's not every word.
Let's forget about it.
Let's drink,
you know.
And it was,
it was always there.
You know,
it's great service.
Let's have a drink.
Shitty food industry.
But we're also in the wine industry
because 50 percent of what you're doing
is selling food to people and the other
50 percent of what you're doing is
selling alcohol to people.
So by default you're part of the people
that sell a liquid drug dealer in that
you're in that world every day and you
go to wine tastings,
you talk with people that sell Silva,
alcoholic bartenders.
You talked to people that sell wine.
You're partake in eating and other your
colleagues,
restaurants and drinking wine.
Next thing you know,
you have a little bit of celebrity.
Had been open for 15 years and you look
back and he'd go to the seven days in a
week or seven days in a week and I drank
six of them.
I don't feel good on Sunday.
I'm just kind of recovering and then
what?
What happens is one week turns into two
to four and then you kind of look back
and you realize in 2017 that you may
have drank 48 weeks out of 52,
you know,
and then it goes quick.
Then it's 10 years and you're a 10 year
restaurant and you've been drinking five
days out of the week for 10 years and
then all of a sudden you kind of have a
problem.
You realize that like my day to day is
based on food and wine.
Right now I don't want my.
It's not making me happy.
I've had all the wines have had.
All the foods are better for it.
Not really.
What am I better for?
Restriction eating less eating,
clean drinking only on very special
occasions.
Do you still drink on special?
I'm completely sober.
No.
Did you make that decision based on the
idea that you weren't able to control it
or just that you.
I'm one of this decision would be to
just completely eliminated textbook case
of a person who couldn't.
Yeah,
I tried several times to stop.
I googled it.
I read about it.
It didn't work.
I was intervention by Fred and my
managers of the restaurants in January
twelfth around their 16th.
I think we figured
and of this year.
Yeah,
I'm eight months sober.
Something.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
And I'm really good.
So you look healthy.
I'm happy man.
That's like the skin every day.
It's just been amazing when that
happens.
Conversation like I was angry.
Remember long time,
you know,
I had like,
no,
it's not only alcoholism,
you know,
I think all alcoholics are codependent
somewhat,
you know,
like it's just,
it had been part of my whole
apprenticeship not being sober for so
many years.
It was all under control and funny for a
very,
very long time.
It was always a big part of my life.
Drinking wine,
eating food,
um,
until it wasn't.
Then one day I was 45,
my relationship with alcohol changed.
I became dark.
I became unhappy.
I had success.
I beautiful children.
I was not happy.
Uh,
you know,
I tried many different things.
Nothing worked.
I was intervention by people that I work
with that are dear to me that I love
very much.
I guess that loved me.
They're tired of watching me,
you know,
make bad decisions.
And I just went to a great rehab called
Chatsworth that
educated me.
It always sitting in a classroom with a
pad and paper for six hours a day
learning about the disease called
alcoholism,
learning about a disease that 30 percent
of the population has a,
you know,
and how and why I was an addict,
at first I was inadequate food then I,
you're not a young age after a traumatic
event.
Then I was an addict about with beer.
Then I was an addict with marijuana,
like we know all drugs and then I was an
addict with wine.
A follow up,
a couple more traumatic events in your
mind,
you know,
horrendous apprenticeship and the stress
of leadership in these restaurants.
And,
you know,
one thing led to another and my
relationship with alcohol became not
positive with help.
I understood through with education,
I understood.
And now everything's great.
It's funny too because I cited it as,
as,
as an example,
you know,
I don't like to tell him,
but maybe it's a little bit of
mentoring,
you know,
I was the canary in the coal mine for
Fred,
you know,
and I decided,
I was like,
fuck,
you know,
after Tony passed,
I was like,
you know,
it was,
I remember I was working in a new
project doing tilings and it's like,
oh,
I heard the news in the morning.
I went,
I went tile all day
and then I couldn't wait to get home and
have like two bottles of wine.
And I was like,
why?
And we were the same about that.
It didn't matter.
Like what we love that appoint look for
example,
we loved mma read,
we love going to the fights.
We were so fortunate would go and see.
We met the FERTITTA brothers.
They discussed like we sat with them at
dinner table,
we met you,
we met all those guys.
David loves wine making all the
winemakers.
We met the best people in the field that
we loved.
Charmed life,
not happy,
like ungrateful fucking little bricks.
Well,
you know,
I think part of the problem is that
alcohol is a depressant.
Correct.
You just,
you,
you get down,
it just
brings you down,
it brings you down,
it brings your energy level down.
It bringing alcohol is a solvent and it
destroys your soft brain tissue and I
was taught that in Rehab.
So when you drink acetone,
I go,
no.
Well,
if it was made by a lovely French
vineyard with Barney Aroma,
but do you.
Do you miss anything about the flavor of
wine with a meal or anything?
Have you ever tried not to.
I don't even know.
I go to wine tastings.
I was just that raw wine and less in Los
Angeles.
I went to taste all the natural wines.
Beautiful natural wine festival and you
can taste them still.
I taste them.
I don't swallow.
I rinse my mouth out.
I'm very much involved in natural wine
and viticulture reading and all that
stuff.
That's got to be so weird to have a
mouthful of delicious one.
Just spit it into a bucket.
No,
it's the same.
Really.
Yeah.
It's like,
because that's why did I drink wine?
I'll factory the nose.
The flavor.
Understanding the winemaker,
his philosophy,
the geography of where the wine comes
from,
his work with,
you know,
with using organic and biodynamic
viticulture.
Not using sulfur,
uh,
just making this amazing organic
beverage with very little intervention.
Natural line without side effects.
I don't have to swallow it because the
drug is the same drug that it's in.
That's in all the other ones that they
can't change flavors.
What's different?
Yes.
You know,
and what I like is more of the story,
the guy,
the vineyard,
the varietals,
this,
you know,
would you eat at a fine restaurant and
have a delicious steak and wine
accompaniment and then just spit it into
a bucket.
I've done it.
Goes to the bathroom.
I had to.
I wasn't really worried.
He shuts his mouth and he goes to the
bathroom.
I was worried.
Mouth full of wine.
Ryan Ryan grave,
our friend from Elaina that worked with
us for years,
Ryan goes to a restaurant and acts for a
bucket and he'll sit with other people
in the wine business and they all drink
wine and he tastes the wine and he has
discussions about wine and he tastes it
and spits it and you know,
he's an alcoholic.
Yeah,
he's a recovered alcoholic three years,
but he's a wine buyer and he's very much
involved.
Was My mentor when
I got out of Rehab because in Rehab they
were telling me you may never be able to
go back to the restaurant was a high
risk of reoffending.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I can't,
like I go,
I don't know anything else.
Like I have no education.
I've been in kitchens and some 17 way
too late for med school and we don't do
well in that.
I really don't want to clean iceberg
lettuce with the fruit and vegetable
store and try to make a go of that.
And you know,
it's funny too,
like even like dealcoholized beer,
nonalcoholic beer,
it's better than alcoholic beer.
What are you talking about?
Heineken?
Zero,
zero man.
Chris.
Really?
Outstanding.
Heineken zero.
Zero.
Outstanding.
It's really good.
I just fine.
Well I've only had like.
Oh duals.
No,
that's good.
Okay,
so.
So Heineken does it correctly.
The,
the,
the order of nonalcoholic beer.
Okay.
In my head is Heineken zero,
zero Carlsberg,
zero grolsch zero roll back to zero and
then everything else is not good after
they let me out to death because I'm
also celiac.
Right.
And there's a Glutenburg they make in
Montreal.
That's no gluten and no alcohol.
Now you can insert any joke you want.
People are signing off the pies,
but I thought these guys are going to
talk about heroin.
Fuck you.
Neat.
Meet though.
Eat meat.
Yes.
I'm sure it was.
I'm sure that's.
This is um,
that's fascinating though that you
actually still tasted and still it's
almost like if you're a heroin,
a heroin addict just scratching the skin
with the needle.
We don't penetrate.
I don't recommend that my,
you know,
my therapist and the people that Rehab
do not recommend that I taste wine and
spit it,
but they don't.
But I have friends again.
I know a lot of Somalis and even I,
I know winemakers,
some of the most famous wine makers in
the world I've met in burgundy in a bed
that are completely sober because they
wanted to break this cycle of.
My great grandfather was an alcoholic
abusive person.
My grandfather was an alcoholic,
My father was an alcoholic,
abusive person and I didn't want to take
over this thousand year old winery.
The legacy of my family.
I didn't want to work here and I'm sure
like,
you know what?
All the Epi genetics stuff,
if you don't drink when your kids are
young and like they might be a thing
where you can stop the passing of the
gene,
but you did sober October.
How'd you do?
Fine?
Yeah.
Well I did love it.
I was the relapse sobriety wasn't.
This was a very crazy sober October
because we added this in St fitness
challenge,
so I was literally working out between
three and a half to five and a half one
day.
Six and a half hours in a day.
It was insane.
One day I did five and a half hours.
I did another hour at night,
six and a half hours in the day it was
was trying to kill each other to see who
could get the most points.
We have a fitness tracker.
We wore a heart rate
monitor.
I heard that the kitchen would score up
the amount of points you would get if I
won the belt right there.
If you get a 70 percent of your max
heart rate,
you get three points per minute.
This is how crazy it got.
Seventy percent of your Max heart rate
is three points per minute.
Eighty percent and above your Max heart
rate is four points per minute.
One day I got a thousand points,
so just think about that.
Think about how many minutes you have to
exercise at 80 percent of your max heart
rate to get a thousand fucking points.
So you think sober help you with
performance or recoup?
I think I was on drugs the entire time.
This is what I think.
I think I was on the endorphins that
come from long range cardio.
There's,
there's,
there's a what I was calling the don't.
I don't give a fuck drug.
There's you get this feeling when you do
Qa,
like everybody always talked about
runner's high and I never really
experienced it even though I'd worked
out really hard my whole life.
I'd never been into like long range
cardio.
I'd never done hours and hours of the
same activity,
just droning on either on a bike or
running.
I'd never really done that.
I'd run hills for the most part and I'm
sure it benefited me and it made me,
made me relaxed.
But is it a totally different level when
you're doing it for three and a half
hours,
four hours a day?
It's true survival mechanism that kicks
in.
It's that,
but it's also,
you feel wonderful.
You,
you have zero anxiety
and you're still benefiting from that?
No,
no,
no.
That's what's interesting.
Like I've been out of the house for a
week now because of the fires,
so we've been running around and the
kids aren't in school so they're here
hanging out with me and they,
they,
you know,
we,
we haven't had a chance to get our stuff
together,
so it's been very stressful.
So I haven't really been working out
much.
I've only worked out once or twice this
week,
so I have more stress.
I feel like a little bit more tense,
a little bit more,
take a deep breath,
calm down.
During October I had none of that.
None of that.
I felt great.
I felt like I was like,
if you could take how I feel and put it
in a pill form and give it to people,
everyone will be hooked on it because
you feel fantastic and I never
understood that.
I would see these people running every
day and I thought they were just
exercise fanatics,
like they just want to be leaner or they
want to just keep maybe the test.
Yeah,
maybe that's what it was,
but I think there are drug addicts,
there are natural drug addicts,
but in a very positive way.
I shouldn't call it drug addicts,
endorphin junkies.
That's what they are.
Yeah.
It makes sense to do that.
You would.
Every cycle in nature,
it's like feast and famine.
It's like running and resting.
You know if you follow,
if you're a hunter gatherer,
you don't hunt every day.
You know,
you follow a cycle is still free for a
month,
you'll hunt,
you'll drag back the meat,
the meat,
Tomi elite a lot,
and then after the next month there's
you'll be quiet,
you'll eat less and then the next month.
So there's very little exercise program
out there that look at it like that.
But if you were to look at it over year,
maybe you'd see it.
Like I see no,
October is more quiet.
I'll do my month in October,
November,
we'll be quiet busy with other things
after that.
I'll go back to it in December.
It's better for the soul too.
You don't have this obsession looming
over you that you have to do it tomorrow
morning and night and like,
you know,
well my take on it was a little bit
different.
My take on it is that everyone's anxiety
levels and all the different stress and
all the things we deal with.
A lot of it is because your body has
capabilities and you're not using even a
small percentage of those capabilities.
So it's always like,
what are we doing?
We're going,
we're going to go.
We're going to go,
oh yeah,
and we're in traffic.
You're moving quickly so you're
constantly aware of all these cars
around you and there's all the stress
and there's very little physical release
that the body takes part in and for most
people,
I mean the the great percentage of our
population lives a sedentary lifestyle.
They sit in their cars until they get to
the office,
they sit in their office until they get
home.
They sit in front of the TV till they go
to sleep.
This is a giant percentage of our
population,
whatever number the number is.
Yeah,
whatever.
It's very normal and occasionally they
work out and when they do,
it's a struggle.
When you force the body into rigorous
exercise on a constant basis,
your body's all the needs and have the
capacity,
the capabilities that it has.
All those needs are satisfied.
So what I found is incredibly low
anxiety levels and I didn't think I had
anxiety.
I'm not an anxious person to the point
where I thought about taking medication
for anxiety,
like I'm nervous or.
But I didn't.
I didn't know how anxiety free I could
be until I did this exercise program for
a month.
See,
I found that in sobriety,
the anxiety I was,
I suffered.
I suffered from anxiety our whole
careers.
Every day,
200,
300 people are coming for dinner at my,
you know,
it's always there.
My scribbling is their staff.
There's 300 people coming.
It's never goes away.
There's always people coming for dinner.
It's throwing happy 400 people every
night.
But when I was drinking that would just
keep the stress going.
Now I'm fine.
It's gone.
There's this magic number and it kept on
hearing and Rehab and he kept on hearing
through therapy.
Sixteen weeks,
16 weeks.
And I was like,
yeah,
shut up.
Fuck.
It was this fucking guys I was telling
you with your 16 weeks or 16 weeks,
man,
big watch.
Sixteen weeks the morning.
Sixteen weeks.
That morning I woke up that morning and
I have my phone set up to 16 weeks and I
had this peace and this joy and this
childhood innocence that I hadn't had in
years on the day.
Sixteen weeks.
Not because I'd been premeditating into
my head and I was looking forward to the
16 weeks.
I didn't believe in it,
but it was literally 16 weeks of
sobriety that brought this.
I was clear that during this club that
had no problem.
I'll be in half an hour.
Yeah,
like as it should be free.
Just don't work.
The lights are out in the restaurant and
five tables are unhappy.
I'm coming down.
Do you think
some of the anxiety was just your body
responding to the fact that you were
poisoning?
Correct.
Think it's the psyche creating reasons
for you to drink.
Your mind is telling you you're
stressed.
I have a quick remedy for it.
Why don't you try drinking that makes
you feel this way?
What's your go to?
I'd be like,
I could taste sometimes when I'd fall
into stacks,
full situations at the restaurant,
three tables.
I don't like a couple of criminal
elements behaving badly at one table,
you know,
maybe I'm the board or of lacking
respect to their waitress.
I might have to get involved and I could
almost taste chardonnay and delivery
glads yeah,
your brain's still plays a trick on
brain was making me high before the
high.
I always like,
why do I taste Chablis in my mouth?
I think it's the same with sugar
addiction too.
You know where people eat sugar or lots
of carbs,
mostly carbs.
Then you're like,
oh man,
I can't.
I have to go for three hours without
eating.
I have to bring something sweet with me
because I'm going to get shaky and then
you have.
It's your.
It's like you're feeding basically.
I don't know if it's your gut biome that
changes,
but you're like feeding a monster inside
of you.
You're not feeding Fred or David,
you're feeding something else.
You know,
like you're planning a weekend at the
cottage or like the kids are going to be
loud.
I'm going to have to bring two more
bottles of wine and have to make sure
that the wine is cold and have to make
sure we have that or like you have to
have friends like that.
I have to make sure you have like for
granola bars because they have to eat
all the time and you know that if you
don't have breakfast you have like a
quick coffee,
you can go to like four or five in the
afternoon and not shaking and getting
cold and Sweaty,
you know?
Well,
depends.
Especially if you have a good healthy
diet.
If your body's not like sugar,
sugar dependent,
I think it's funny every time you know,
sometimes we fall off the wagon and
stuff not as pretty solid for a few
years.
I think that two weeks of drinking more
water,
having walks and not eating ice cream
and fries and two weeks of home cooked
meals and water cutting down on coffee
because that dude will fuck with your
anxiety,
you know?
Sure.
We noticed that both of us,
all of this,
like so many diseases,
is based simply on overconsumption just
period over consumption of cigarettes,
over consumption of alcohol,
over consumption of sugar,
over consumption of meat,
carbs like restriction brings clarity.
December restriction diets are one of
the best remedies for people with
autoimmune diseases.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well,
cut down almost everything out of your.
One of the things that people are doing
today that's very popular but keep
talking about this unfortunately is the
carnivore diet because Jordan Peterson
made it very popular when he was on the
podcast.
It's really fascinating.
There's a spike.
If you look at the Google search results
or carnivore,
it's July
of 2018.
He goes like this.
He takes off because that's the day that
Jordan was on the podcast,
so he's in the podcast,
you know,
fucking whatever amount of millions of
people listening to this in order and
because of his ranting and raving about
the positive benefits that he's
experienced.
So I got on the carnivore diet.
People really got into it,
so I got into it as well,
like what is it about this?
So I started consulting a lot of actual
nutrition experts and scientists and
what they believe is what's going on as
calorie restriction.
That because of the fact that you're
only.
Jordan is only eating steak with salt
and drinking water,
that is all he's consuming and he feels
fantastic because it's a lean steak.
Now real estate,
yes,
fatty.
So then you can't do much because you
have the fat.
You're feeling full.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That fat is important.
Yeah.
And because this is quite a few
autoimmune issues that he had went away.
He was having receding gums that went
away.
Uh,
he uh,
was having severe depression and anxiety
and all these different issues that went
away.
You announced a tremendous amount of
weight.
His body leaned up and science.
The scientists that have talked about,
you know,
this is a very new thing for people to
embark on this and do it on a mass scale
because quite a few people doing it.
What they're attributing it to is the
calorie restriction is that because of
the fact that you're in,
you really can't eat that much stake if
you eat a steak,
you know,
it might be a thousand calories.
Whereas if immediate,
full,
big fixed day closet galleries the
stakes a lot at stake.
Right?
Yeah.
But I mean he might be eating two of
those in a day.
Whereas if you're eating French fries
and soda,
empty calories,
you're getting shade here.
Like way more than that.
Like what do you think?
Uh,
an 18 ounce rib eye is if you had a
guest calorically 11,
1800 and 800,
800 bands.
If you have like the end of the rack in.
Okay.
So let's,
let's just get crazy.
Let's call it 700.
It's probably like at 1700 calories a
day because he's not putting cream in
the coffee's not having a seven.
That's the water went steak when I
started eating.
No gluten,
right.
It's fully diagnosed,
right?
I'm not making this up.
I stopped,
I stopped eating gluten.
It gets flagged every day.
What does that mean?
Everybody gets crazy about the gluten
go.
He is like here it,
I don't want to hear it.
We don't want to like what I said,
but what does it mean?
You don't eat gluten?
Smoking cigarettes,
like come on now.
But what does it mean?
No gluten.
It means that you don't go to,
you know,
drive drew,
slip,
right?
There's no options out there in the fast
food world.
There's no.
So I have to plan my day,
so I like,
I'll eat a piece of meat for breakfast
with or eggs or whatever,
and then I won't eat until like show up
at work or at home later and eat.
So it's with you've excluded that
counts.
Yes.
It's not that this steak is so good for
you,
is that you're not eating
all this processed food anymore because
you can't eat it anymore.
That's what the scientists are saying.
But the people that are pro meet,
it's really fascinating because they're
just as culty as the vegans are.
The people that are the real pro
carnivore diets,
they want you to think that it's the
meat that's healing and the meat that's
helping them meet,
that's making them lean that meat.
Well,
it's not hurting you.
I mean it's,
it's nutritious.
I mean there's a lot of real nutrients
and red meat and this is also a problem
with a lot of studies that people have
that a lot of vegans love to cite about
heart attacks,
strokes,
cancer in relationship to meet these
epidemiology studies that were.
There essentially is they're saying,
look,
when you look at people that eat meat
five days a week,
these are the people that have higher
instances of cancer,
higher instances of diabetes,
all these different things.
Where they're not taking into
consideration is they're not just eating
meat.
They're usually eating a cheeseburger
with fries and a soda and there's all
this sugar.
It's before dinner and all this bullshit
that's that's involved with the meat.
There's not any studies that show that
people who eat a lot or a 12 ounce grass
fed steak with a good plate of sauteed
spinach and olive oil and garlic,
that these people are getting cancer and
I can't make a nutritional study or
that's impossible.
People fundamentally lie,
so you cannot have people you cannot say
like,
this is coco fat and beef tenderloin.
I'm going to give you a week portion.
You'll go home.
Then you come to report.
We do blood tests.
You get anecdotal evidence from people
that talk about their own personal diet,
but yeah,
it's,
it's very difficult and it's also very
ideologically based.
I mean,
whether it's on one side with the vegans
are the other side where the carnivore
diet people,
I find the same psychological
characteristics in both groups.
They want to convert people,
they want to proselytize,
they want people to think that their way
is the right way and they,
they are not honest about health issues
that they're having.
You should make like a,
a conference on a deserted island,
you know,
and uh,
Richmond's gas.
So like a Bruce Lee movie and knew you
invite the vegans on one side and you
don't tell them you're also inviting the
other,
you know,
and then both groups it just have like
a,
well both think the other group is going
to drop dead at any second.
Now the proof is in the pudding.
If somebody is on your podcast to talk
about eating meat,
that he's alive and he's not dead.
So it works,
you know,
like white look any further.
Well,
who knows how long they're gonna last.
none of us are getting out of this alive
now,
that's for sure.
When it comes to meat,
do you guys prefer a grass fed beef or
do you like a corn fed?
Because I had this discussion with Tony
and he was telling me that he actually
likes corn fed beef.
He's like,
it's a fattier that there's two schools
of thought and then there's two schools
of what is quality beef,
right.
So one school say,
yeah,
quality beef is organic
animal pasture raised,
eating grass flavors different.
It's not as tender,
but it is high quality beef.
Okay.
Then the other of course says,
you know,
a cow Usta,
prime grow,
corn fed,
incredible marbling,
ridiculous fat content.
Restricted motion.
I'd say a lesser quality beef.
Okay.
Then then the other,
but they all start eating wise.
They'll pastored at first eating wise,
you know,
gram per pound for pound.
The corn fed steak will be more
delicious.
Okay.
For some people.
And then for some people,
the other one will be,
in my mind,
the grass fed organic pasture beef with
a different flavor.
For me as a higher quality animal,
I.
I prefer that taste correct.
I feel it's a Richard taste.
It's a denser,
darker meat more than iron taste.
Yeah.
I just like it better and I do like a
corn fed steak.
I do,
but in the general public,
the steak eating public that come to
restaurants and counter more grow corn
fed beef that and the first judge of
character to the quality of that meat is
tendering.
It's tenderness.
It's marble.
It's not tender.
That's a reoccurring thing that we fight
with every day.
A job while the tender to see the 16
ounce fog walk tender.
I know.
I mean,
what are they looking for?
Are Your teeth work?
But we get to take sent back.
It'll be big
because
it's too tough.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's not always usually go to the
steakhouse and it's tender because
you're bringing your serving a grass
fed,
grass fed,
grass fed steak that's not as marbled
as.
It's not organic.
Well,
it's an.
It's an animal that's healthy,
but you can also have.
It's an upgrade though.
It's like the natural wine versus
conventional wind fight.
Right.
Then we're having,
you know.
Yeah,
but it's also.
We're calling it binary now.
It's like it's only corn or it's only
grass.
No,
I think the solution is maybe a little
bit of corn,
a little bit of barley,
but mostly grassfed,
you know,
a brief finish and like quality grains,
why not?
And then there's a whole other point I'd
like to raise giant feedlot.
I like to sell beef,
uh,
in my restaurant that comes from very
close to my restaurant,
you know?
Yeah.
When we opened joe beef at the
beginning,
when that first book,
the first book was written,
a beef was a problem back then,
you know,
local beef was kind of difficult and you
know,
we were buying beef from larger
wholesalers and we,
if we didn't how to read the barcodes on
the boxes,
they would say it was Canadian beef,
but it might not be safe.
It might be north northern USA beef,
but we didn't know because only a
professional could read the Barcode.
But they were saying it was Canadian.
But one day I had a professional come
into the restaurant and he said,
no,
actually this beef is.
Yeah,
from a company with investiture is in
Canada,
but this is from Western Australia and I
said I don't want to serve anything in
my restaurant from Western Australia
that's super far removed from the menu
or seek alternatives.
Uh,
but it's a business that's complex
because there's past years in feed,
lots slaughterhouse and packers.
Right.
And it's not like we have lambs,
get a baby lamb that come from the
parents lamb and then they farm,
they raised the lamb and they bring it
to the slaughterhouse themselves and
then we get a lamb.
Beef is like,
you can get it.
It's like tracing bourbons,
you know,
it's like trading and brokerage and
stuff and we're not,
it's the most sketchy item on a
restaurant menu.
Like I know that I bought land from you
and I know I bought rabbit from Beatrice
and I know I got goat cheese from this
family and all of the products in my
restaurant.
I know exactly the farm and the farmer
beef is always dicey because beef always
goes to the packer,
be followers,
goes to the distributor you fall to.
And the general public only really eats
two cuts of beef in restaurants,
you know,
three cuts,
the tenderloin,
the,
what do you call it in English though?
I'll throw a coat,
you know the lines,
right?
That's what people lead.
But in the hamburgers,
beefs or not that,
you know,
there's two big humps and there's two
big shoulders and there's a lot of
braids.
So,
you know,
it's uh,
it's difficult to see that documentary
on steak.
Yeah,
we were.
Yeah.
You were in it,
right?
What did you think of that,
their conclusions and what was the
conclusion?
Well,
it just basically we're saying to Peter
Luger's steakhouse in Brooklyn's a
greatest stake in the world.
The Usda prime corn fed for taste.
Maybe it's good.
It's good restaurant.
Good story.
Good history,
great restaurants.
There are just a few months ago.
It's very good.
Yeah.
Very good.
But,
um,
but again,
it's a subjective thing,
right?
The flavor in terms of like what you
actually look for.
And they as they were talking about like
your customers saying they're accustomed
to a certain type of meat.
Like they were saying that their
customers are accustomed to this,
they're not interested in grass fed
anything bad.
I understand that,
you know,
they've been doing that for a long time
and grading that beef that way and I
don't think they should change ever.
Not based on anything.
Right.
It's a great place where you get
consistency.
I mean,
you go there,
you get this fantastic steak.
It's,
I mean it's so old world too and you get
in there that.
I mean,
how long has Peter Luger's been around
for
God?
Forever.
Forever hundred.
Twenty years or something insane like
that.
And they get the money.
Shit like that.
At my trial is very old steak
restaurant.
Moishe's is a famous restaurant in
Montreal and they,
you know,
they do have their beef program and they
should not change because there's new
conversations happening.
He knows what he's doing.
Lenny lighter and he should do,
you know,
keep on doing that in a small
restaurant.
Let's say that fred marginal characters
like Fred and I own,
I always see it like it's not a those
restaurants maybe or public places.
My restaurant is my restaurant,
which I want to do what I want in.
Right.
It's not,
it's not at the.
I don't,
we don't listen so much to the public,
you know,
I,
I serve at my pleasure.
Not the customer.
The customer is always right.
It's the customers often wrong and I'm
always right because we can do salmon.
I play the music,
I want to serve the food we want to and
I served the wines we want to and if you
don't like it,
you don't have to come.
It's our,
but it's this restaurant is for us.
That's one of the things that I learned
from watching Bourdain's original show
that no reservation show and that it
changed my opinion on things because I
didn't have a strong opinion on food
before that.
Other than that I really liked it.
I didn't think of it as an art form and
watching his show and seeing the passion
of his,
his appreciation for food and for the
way it's the way it's grown and brought
to the table and the production of it.
And then ultimately the flavor of it and
the taste.
And,
and his admiration for chefs and you
guys as well,
his,
his advert,
his admiration for it and his,
his appreciation for the way
everything's put together made me
realize like,
oh,
this is an art form.
It's a craft.
And,
and you know,
Tony did something.
Tony was the most faithful,
most like we were so lucky to be on that
ship with him.
You know,
that he took us a board and you could
see he had the same apprenticeship we
did,
you know,
like suffering and like big bistro
stroke kitchens and stuff.
And you think about it,
the guy,
he didn't make the promise to himself
that when he'd get rich and famous he
was going to buy a big house and not
talk to people.
He helped every cook not walk out of the
kitchen and get famous but get a voice,
you know,
television show.
The work he did in private is not look
like a dirty guy that makes the pasta in
the back.
You know,
all of a sudden it's like,
yeah,
the manager in the suit and the owners.
But who's the guy in the back?
He had appreciation for everybody and he
had a real passion for the process and
the marginal character is like,
there's lots of commercial restaurants
in the city of Montreal in any given
city of that he went to.
He was able to isolate,
let's say,
the marginal characters in every city
that,
you know,
we're,
we're historically bound kind of Fred
and I practice a weird faction of French
cooking called cuisine bourgeoise and
only kind of Tony and a handful of other
guys couldn't look at what we do and go,
oh,
those fuckers,
they're,
they're up to that.
No one.
He goes,
you guys are the only people,
the last of the Mohicans that do this
kind of food.
I mean,
no.
Yeah,
know we can't stop.
We got to keep on with what a great guy
to get it to.
Yeah.
Because nobody does,
right.
Nobody understands.
Like,
you know the rabbit hole where down Tony
did the.
Yeah,
he,
he really did a deeply influenced my
appreciation for food in the way I think
about it.
And again,
treating it as an art form,
which I just thought it was just
delicious.
I didn't think of it as like,
oh,
these guys are making temporary art.
They're making art.
You're going to,
you're going to enjoy.
Now you know you're,
you're,
you can't put it on film.
I mean you can,
but you're not going to get it all.
You're just gonna want to go out and
experience it.
Yeah.
Ultimately food is you can't we go and
do like we were asked to do like
demonstrations,
you know,
you can go on a big stage.
It's 5,000
people to talk about food or make like
little crackers with smoked salmon
onstage.
Food is not fit for a stage.
No.
Food is for a table for us to enjoy it
with a fork and knife.
We talk about it and go hunting.
That's what food is.
Paypal offers food shows all the time
and it doesn't work.
What's the concept?
Well,
you guys can be in a pickup truck and
you go and visit your suppliers and
maybe I have a bottle of wine with them
after.
I was like,
dude,
like we worked hard not to copy or
fellow,
you know,
culinarians.
Yeah.
You look at TV producers are out there
just like blatantly proposing the
previous show to you again.
Well that's one of the things
right after anthony died,
there was some talk about,
oh
Hugh Ramsay doing some very similar show
in the outcry against it was enormous.
I mean he was just getting assaulted
online.
I mean it was crazy
that everybody that I was talking to our
agents who represents us for our book
and she was saying like,
it was the same.
All the big production companies are
being paraded by people pitching who is
going to be the next Tony,
right.
You know,
I don't want to say that,
but one of the character and you guys
you could take over.
Yeah,
you could do it because you guys track,
you know,
the way it went in West Virginia and it
wasn't like Republican or Democrat.
Like he went to places.
He's like,
yeah sure I have my views,
but let's break bread.
You know.
And I always said that like,
all our countries are divided on issues,
but they're nobody that overlaps them
with a coherent vision.
Everybody
loves each other when there's delicious
food on the table that and guys like you
with like a clear view and irrational
and science based and evidence based
view on things.
And like Tony just have such a voice now
in our countries that it's.
I could see you doing a food show.
I love food,
but I don't,
I'll never do a food show and I just
can't imagine not because you ask
questions.
I like doing show.
I mean I love having guys like you on
and talking about food,
but it takes a special type of person to
want to travel 300 days a year,
you know,
and that's essentially what Tony was
doing.
And I think that has a massive toll.
Um,
it,
it takes a massive toll on your body.
It takes a massive toll on your psyche
family everyday.
It's not healthy.
I know there's not enough Melatonin or
like cbd or the lenses to help you with
that.
I traveled more than enough already and
I've cut my traveling way back.
I'm down to only 10.
UFC is a year now,
and I do,
you know,
comedy around that and stand up comedy.
But I,
I consciously make the effort to travel
much less because I just don't think
it's good.
I just don't think it's good for you.
And um,
and also that road life,
you know,
the,
the drinking and all that other stuff
that comes with it that accentuates all
the problems that you have with,
uh,
with travel.
And I think that's also one of the
things that,
um,
was,
was dragging tony down when he would
talk about the sadness and the
loneliness of being on the road.
I can't help but from knowing him and
partying with him,
I can't help but the thought that a lot
of that was probably accentuated by the
alcohol consumption and you know,
and you guys could speak to that now
that you're,
you're,
you're clean and you're not experiencing
the,
those rugged hangovers every morning.
I always,
always worried for Tony that way.
Just so you know,
the hotel,
living planes,
trains and automobiles constantly and it
wasn't like for a year it was like,
Hey,
well years,
sad life if the watch river monsters at
11 in the morning,
burping Jamison and I'm referring to
many occasions in our life where like
you're traveling in a hotel room and you
were in a beautiful place,
but like just,
you feel weird.
Yeah,
I've,
I've taken steps to mitigate some of
that.
One of the big ones is I travel with
friends.
I'm bring really good comics to work
with me on the road so that when I'm in
these cities,
I'm in these cities with friends and we
just go.
It's like they're family.
So we go,
we'll go eat together,
we'll go work out together,
you know,
and try to keep the unhealthy shit to a
minimum.
Plus I'm more of a marijuana
enthusiastic than I am a drinker.
Anyway.
It's legal and back now we stores in the
entire country,
Canada as well in America.
They're connected as usual.
We got a little bit the special
treatment,
you know,
they're everywhere else in French.
Then on top of yet you
can't grow,
what do you call it,
in cannabis?
Cannabis.
You can't grow,
can't grow,
and you have to only consume the
government's going grow anyway.
I'm not worried about that government.
So you know what they did,
right?
Yeah.
It's like a,
you know,
we have a monopoly liquor board,
so we have like storage or commissioner
commissioner.
Now we have the cannabis commission.
So what they did,
it got legal and October 17th at
midnight.
The stores we're opening October 17th at
10 in the morning.
The cops were giving tickets to people
smoking weed during that little layover
time because they knew that it was
impossible.
They bought it legally.
So some people get ticketed for smoking.
Illegal.
We'd align it for legal weed.
Oh God.
What a bunch of asks.
Hey,
we just drank the Koolaid on that one.
I think you know,
but it's good.
We'll put more money into Medicare.
Well,
I think
ultimately lead to relaxing of people's
opinions and ideas about marijuana and
what it is,
but I also think that marijuana,
just like alcohol can be used as a
crutch and it could eventually overcome
your life.
I like it,
but I like it.
I like it.
Uh,
every now and again,
you know,
and one of the things that came out of
last year,
sober October was taking a whole month
off of it,
realizing that hey,
I don't need it.
I can,
I can function fine without it,
but it made me more apprehensive about
regular use.
Like instead of using it every day,
I'll use it a day,
a week or two days a week or something
like that.
And I,
and I appreciate it more when it does
happen,
when,
when I do get high with my friends on
Friday night or something like that,
it's like it means something like we're,
we're,
it's almost like a sacrament.
Like we're experiencing a little moment
together and just having fun.
That's the proof though.
What you just said is the proof that you
don't have addiction issues.
You see,
I couldn't be able to prove that I
smoked marijuana responsibly once in my
life that I drank alcohol once in my
life that you know,
that I did drugs responsibly,
so I'm fascinated by brought some,
some of our cooks that were here in la
with us to a restaurant and we had a
beautiful dinner and I ordered them a
bottle of wine and they barely finished
it and I didn't understand the first
bottle of wine.
I was like,
what do you guys want more as I think I
would've paid for nine and they had one
and I was just sitting there.
I told Fred,
I go,
I don't really.
What is it like to be in that
environment and watching people glass
over,
like see,
see the drunk we use.
We say that all the time.
We used to think that like everybody was
drunk.
It was smashed.
No,
there was only me was like the beer
goggles in it with everybody realized
now that like everybody at the
restaurants generally like nine out of
10 times drink quite responsibly.
Otherwise it'd be just accidents
everywhere in violence everywhere you
turn right?
Yeah,
and I realize a lot of the people that
I'm friends with drink responsibly,
they can have a glass of wine with
lunch.
Uh,
me and fred opened a bottle of wine at
lunch.
We go til 10:30
until we couldn't it anymore.
And then that was it.
You know,
we,
we did last time we came to La,
we did a hell's kitchen.
Okay.
We're judged for showing ostriches who's
disgusting?
Ostriches Burger before mutual fund
rutgers as ostrich Burger.
It's actually delicious.
It's really bloody right.
And there's that thing for a cooking
shows like that.
It's regulated by the Gaming Commission,
so they have to keep the camera rolling
and they're not allowed to touch the
dishes because they are the object of
the competition.
So you take your break,
you go to the green room,
your way,
they're cleaning up the kitchen now.
The food sits on the past there like for
two hours and you come back,
you sit at a table and there's like rare
ostrich vendor line that's been sitting
for two hours.
Then they just post cook.
Yeah.
And you have to judge like,
wait a minute,
you,
you're judging food that was cooked two
hours ago.
TV.
That's so fucking.
And I felt like,
again that's insulting for,
for guys like,
you know.
But the thing is like if I felt so bad
because there's people who put a job on
hold,
they left their kids at home.
They made it.
I'm in the casting.
I was selected to be part of the kitchen
and then we say something in that
regard.
It's good.
I hate us right now,
right?
No,
the show's great.
But I felt like I felt sad.
But that's all that to say that whenever
we came we stayed by the airport.
You know,
we,
we stayed at a.
just so you can get into their quick
frozen.
Margarita is at the hotel bar.
11 o'clock.
We're into a whirlpool at the radisson.
Radison Ortho.
So sad.
Having cocktails and encounters,
that hotel life can be fucking sad,
man.
I know.
I get it.
It's like.
And now we're like completely not
drinking.
They got us a room and we're staying at
the chateau and I never did.
I never thought it stay there.
I would really love to get drunk at the
Chateau Marmont you did once,
but not this time.
But yeah,
that's like a spot,
you know,
I've been here forever.
I've never even gone in that building.
It's beautiful.
Maybe it did once.
I might have.
I think it was there once for like a TV
thing that I had to do,
like a one of those party things in like
the nineties.
I think I went once.
It's funny because there's like really
like,
you know,
like be list Hollywood stars,
like hanging out at the pool,
drinking champagne cocktails,
trying to be cool smoking blunts and try
to pick up girls.
Tony used to stay.
He said get a villa there.
When he was writing,
he used to stay there.
He told me he loved it.
He just loved everything about the feel
of it.
The whole,
the dirtiness of the Raleigh hotel with
him in Miami.
He loved that place too.
Dirty spots.
Other Raleigh was fun.
That that's how Tony was,
you know,
he's like
guys,
I like old food like you do.
What if we do a dinner based on like a
old transatlantic ship,
like boats,
like dining room.
So we get repaired,
repair,
Daniele Ballou bunch of guys.
He's like,
Ah,
put you up at the Raleigh.
We're just gonna do that one dinner,
but we're just gonna hang out for a week
after you.
And we're in the pool and the pool
everyday making cigarettes.
Ottavia was like there with a kid and a
rash guard all the time.
We went through a Cyborg,
Roberto Abreu.
We went to school there and I was just
like,
starting in killer sister.
How long have you been doing Jujitsu
now?
I did it for a year.
Solid and I stopped because a,
at a back surgery.
Oh,
disks?
Yeah.
What,
what's uh,
what's going on?
It's totally fixed,
but I keep a towel.
So,
surgery,
what did you have wrong?
Uh,
it was um,
uh,
stenos shortening of the disc.
Yeah.
And then compression and then they,
they went in and chip some parts out.
[inaudible]
in retrospect.
And I spoke to some rheumatologists and
it's interesting you're talking about
like,
um,
Jordan Peterson because the auto immune
thing can be everywhere,
right?
And now the doctor says like maybe
Celiac caused the inflammation and so
many places,
that's what I would say and all that,
like maybe the drinking to the
inclination towards abuse,
you know,
this inclination towards depression,
this back problem,
this,
it's all related to that.
And again,
the proof is in the pudding.
I don't eat bread,
I don't eat sweets very little.
I mostly meet and I feel 100 times
better.
I don't give a fuck if fits in my head
for sober now.
Four months,
five months.
Well,
so it works.
I don't think that it's in your head,
but it's definitely been proven that all
those foods cause inflammation.
But I do think that Jujitsu in
particular is ruthless on your back
because of the torsions.
Well,
it's just,
you know,
big people on top of you.
You're yanking them around,
you're moving it back.
And very and very few people strengthen
their back.
That's a,
that's a big issue.
And after we're done here,
I'm going to take you into my gym and
I'm going to show you some machines that
I bought specifically to strengthen my
back.
I've had some disc issues too,
and the doctors are pretty adamant about
putting me under the knife.
And,
uh,
I,
I just didn't like the idea of it.
I've had many surgeries.
I've had both my knees reconstructed.
I know when you need surgery,
when you don't.
And the more I looked into it,
the more I realize that there's doctors
that they have a hammer.
So everything's a nail that's a nail.
Let me just fucking whack that thing.
They're not like,
oh,
you're going to have to change your
diet.
You're going to have to lose some
weight.
You're going to have to strengthen those
muscles around your back.
And if you do do that,
I find that the results are superior in
many cases.
It's a combination like yoga works
wonderfully for testing.
Yoga.
Decompression of the spine is,
is critical because you're always
compressing.
You always like,
well,
these chairs,
we're sitting in these chairs from a
company called fully and they're called
capisce co's.
And these are Ergonomic chairs,
you know,
as we've been sitting in this place,
it's two and a half hours in the
podcast.
Now we don't,
our backs aren't hurting.
They feel good too.
They're comfortable as like.
So I knew there was a solution how to
find the solution.
Luckily this,
this company contacted me and sent us
these chairs.
This is what we needed.
I try to fucking shitload of chairs
before that.
But it was the same thing with the
exercises.
I knew there was a solution.
I had to figure out what it was.
I tried decompression.
I tried a bunch of different forms of
decompression.
I figured out the best ones,
you know,
I have those,
um,
those things are the way you hang by
your ankle.
What the fuck is the name of that
company?
Hooks known the upside down thing.
God Damn it.
They're a sponsor of the podcast.
Sex swings.
Teeter totter.
Teeter makes those like,
just relaxing in those.
We have one back there.
You clamp your ankles in,
just collect that back.
Just stretch out again.
And then there's a bunch of different
exercise that I do with yoga this
stretcher back out as well.
We're in a constant state of
compression,
right?
Constant gravity,
constant pushing you down.
And a guy like me,
I'm always lifting weights to some.
You've got these heavy is pushing up and
got up,
got to spend as much time.
But we'll lengthening as you do pushing
down.
And you also have to stretch everything
out because the more your hamstrings are
tight,
it's going to pull down on your back.
A lot of people that have back pains,
it's a connected feet.
Dangling tight hamstrings.
Yeah.
I have a theory through the.
Like a lot of things starts in school,
you know,
because you look at kids.
I have two boys and one daughter,
you know Henry,
Ivan and Eleanor and they five,
seven,
nine.
They can do monkey bars,
pull ups,
muscle ups,
you know like they do judo,
they play hockey.
They're very active.
But school,
the way that physically a classroom is
designed is wrong.
It's like putting them in a cast for the
next 15 years and then they're going to
come out of high school.
Like I was unable to climb a rope.
I'm able to do monkey bars,
unable to do anything right.
And then they're going to go through
more school and sit down for more times,
you know,
so they don't get enough physical
activity and not even close.
No,
not even the education towards it.
Not even the education nutricia yeah.
And they get graded and evaluated on how
well they listened in gym class,
which is completely insane.
Yeah,
it really is.
I mean it was just making them sit down
for all that time during the day.
We're just preparing them for some job
that's going to be a natural in the
first place.
Good little taxpayers and look,
look at it too.
That's a model of school that was based
on like religious schools,
you know,
and,
and like old Catholic schools,
let's say in Quebec.
How did you keep them from being
distracted?
You know,
the ruler,
the fingers.
You go to the corner of the leather
strap now we haven't changed the
classroom,
the schedule and the curriculum barely,
but there's no more straps,
so like,
okay,
we haven't changed anything.
Like it's normal that it particularly
little boys don't listen in school that
well.
We have to find a way.
We have to redesign school from like the
schedule,
the design of the classroom,
the hallways,
the introduction,
you know,
like we have to bring restaurants back
into school cafeteria and all that.
No,
it like cafeteria is and I don't know if
it's you the talk with Jeff Bridges
about that because he's in the school
lunches thing and the problem with
school lunches is that if you subsidize
half the kids then you have a kid with
like a badge here that says like poor,
you know?
So the only way to do that then I know
some people are a bit anti socialist,
but you have to feed all the kids.
Right?
It's crucial.
I mean the idea that that's a problem.
I mean Jesus Christ,
we're talking about food and also the
sense of community that's established
when everybody eats together.
You're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna create this rift between
students where you establish that one
student is poor than the other ones just
going to fuck them up already,
you know it's going to already make them
insecure
unless you have the labor force with the
kids,
like not to say that we're gonna make
the kids work,
but it's to be a learning experience and
people can take their turns.
Preparing family meals inside of the
school system is a valuable tool
tool and if it was done and handled with
respect and appreciation,
if they have classes perhaps that showed
how important food is,
I mean maybe even show an episode of no
reservations or you know,
or parts unknown and show how people can
appreciate food and what food really is
and how great it would be.
I mean,
and also it would open their eyes to the
possibility of food as a career of,
you know,
of getting into the same position that
you guys are in.
I mean,
this is something that's never
discussed.
Mean.
When was the last time a kid was
encouraged to become a chef.
You know,
is a standup comedian,
you know,
you never get encouraged to stand up
comedian,
they just call you a fuck up and try to
put you on drugs.
It never comes out when they do a survey
and you know,
90 percent of our labor force inside the
restaurants is you could anybody who
cooks inside the restaurants is someone
who didn't work inside the traditional
school system.
You know,
we,
we employ a dropouts.
Yeah.
But brilliant.
You know,
we've,
there's brilliant people on the team.
They just,
the school system did not work for them.
Well that's the same thing with both of
my jobs,
whether it's the UFC or whether it's
standup comedy.
Everyone that I'm close with is a fuck
up in the traditional sense like we
didn't.
None of us fit in.
It's very few people that get into
standup comedy that were thriving and
some other career.
Most of us were extremely frustrated
with traditional environments and most
of us didn't do well in school because
we felt and just couldn't wait to get
nightmares about going back to school.
Do you have add as a child?
I'm sure I got it all,
whatever the fuck it is,
whatever it is that gives you energy
that makes you better at stuff,
and I got that.
They'll call it a bad thing and say
like,
you can't concentrate while I'm fucking
bored.
Give them knocking,
treated me something that I can
concentrate on,
give me something that I actually enjoy.
I got a lot of energy.
It's not that there's something wrong
with me and said,
I have no interest and what they're
selling and it's being sold by some
underpaid under motivated person who
really is just following some sort of a
curriculum and they have to do that
because they want to keep their job.
This is what kids are being subjected to
all across the world in the most fertile
time of their life in terms of their
imagination,
their creativity and their free time.
Frontal cortex is a sponge.
They're ready to take everything and no
one would ever say to some kid who's
cracking jokes in class and running
around being a fool.
No one would ever say,
hey,
you ever thought about being a comedian?
Like,
no one says that.
Just never comes up,
but meanwhile everybody loves comedians.
People love to go see comedy,
but nobody ever says to some fuck up
kid,
hey man,
you might be a comic.
You know,
it just doesn't.
Doesn't come up.
They will do the test and like David was
supposed to be a travel agent was I was
supposed to be a golf pro in Canada.
You're supposed to be a golf pro at a
coffee.
No,
and then according to the questionnaire,
and one of my friend who flies planes
was supposed think to be a folly.
Artists make sounds of horses with
coconuts and movies like,
yeah,
yeah.
That's fine.
That's what they told them.
After the questionnaire,
what the fuck kind of questionnaire do
you guys have in Canada?
The success of restaurant though you
have to think though,
is due to a lot of very sad people that
have gone through the academic process.
I have a disproportion amount of lawyers
and professionals and people who wear
suits that love to come to the
restaurant and drink wine and let the
dog stopped barking inside their heads
because they're really fucking
miserable.
You know,
when you spent your whole day in the
72nd floor of the IBM tower downtown in
your cubicle,
punching data into graphs and taking a
licking from your boss,
who's also a suit,
just a constant.
You can't wait to get to Joe beef and,
you know,
relax or like the Michael Douglas movie
there.
Enough.
Oh,
what was that called?
Falling down.
Yeah.
Enough with his,
with Jello.
What is enough?
What does she do?
Gigli me.
No,
no,
no enough.
Is the movie with Delaware where she,
uh,
she avengers,
some ex boyfriend that traumatizes her
intubated is.
It's great.
I love movies.
Okay.
There's something about airplanes.
I don't know if the,
the added the altitude and the that like
stupid movies are great and you're in
the sky and nothing covered.
He's quite the movie buff.
He loves Notting Hill.
He was like,
that's a beautiful movie.
I was like,
I don't even know what that's about.
What's not in Hilbert?
That's the movie with Hugh Grant.
Oh,
Christ.
I can't remember what it's about.
You know what I loved?
I loved the night that the rocksbury
started drinking again,
man.
Julian Robertson,
Hugh Grant.
We were just,
you know,
the shadow is right by the Roxbury.
It was.
I couldn't wait to just get out of the
car,
go walk there,
take a picture of it,
and just like try to show like I sent
the picture to everyone.
Nobody reacted,
dude.
It's the Rocksbury you see you saw that
movie night at the Roxbury?
Yeah.
I saw the movie and for me to travel
there is like,
you liked that?
You like that movie?
I loved it.
Really?
Yeah.
Hm.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Same reaction.
What else is your favorite movie alone
in the Wilderness?
Dick Panicky lives.
Great.
You saw that movie,
the guy that whittles a hinges for his
house in Alaska show.
That's a must view.
Oh,
is it really just like once a year you
watch really alone in the wilderness.
Dick Prentky.
Can you bring that up on the thing?
What is that?
The guy runs away like,
no,
no.
I'll ask you a guy who just moves and
lives in the woods for the rest of his
life.
The French love Jerry Lewis.
Now they plan on their mock pbs as a
fundraiser every year.
Wow.
Why is this guy put his ipod and films
himself and he.
He carves everything you need hunts
every year.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
I have,
I did not know this guy's name,
so I thought you were talking about a
move.
This is like a documentary
self made,
so he literally gets dropped off there
with an ax and then he builds a house
and then he kills a goat and then,
you know.
Yeah,
I do remember this guy in interviews
that I,
I think I probably saw on youtube,
but yeah,
he builds his own house and log cabins
and shit.
Yeah.
This guy.
Oh,
that's such a beautiful.
Did you guys ever see that vice piece
about the guy who lives in the Arctic
Hind Mo Heimos Arctic adventure?
No,
fucking amazing man.
It's a vice guide to travel piece where
this guy got a very small cabin in the
Arctic in the 19 seventies and he's been
there since the only thing he's ever
seen from nine slash 11 and some
photographs.
He had no idea what's happening when it
happened.
Um,
he is,
he still loved Michael Jackson,
I don't know,
but this is it.
This,
this guy lives alone in Alaska with his
wife in the Arctic national refuge and
uh,
you have to get in with a float plane
and he just hunted Caribou and he lives
with his family.
Wife is into it and they have children
together and children leave and
eventually went on to college.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
One of their kids was two years old,
died in a canoe accident.
The canoe fell over and the kid fell
into the river and they revisit the spot
at the time of her birthday.
And it's really intense.
But this guy really believes that people
are there.
They're happier and healthier when they
live a hunter gatherer lifestyle and
choleric restriction.
All he does is eat Caribou.
I mean,
the guy is out there,
uh,
eating Caribou and during the time where
they're filming this,
his cabin and is caribou stash,
gets attacked by a grizzly bear and he
shoots the grizzly bear on film.
He chases it down to the night and
blasts it.
One of the grizzly bears and eaten one
of his dogs.
I mean,
this is motherfuckers out there living,
but he was like,
he's a very smart guy.
He's not what you would think when you
think of someone like this,
you think of someone who has some weird
kind of inbred halfwit who's living up
there.
I know he's very intelligent,
very introvert.
Maybe,
maybe introverted for sure,
but it doesn't seem to have a hard time
talking to people.
So I don't know if he's introverted,
but I mean he,
he's definitely restricted his,
his access to dialogue.
I mean,
he's out there alone in the forest by
himself,
but he makes a very compelling point
that there's a natural feeling that he
gets from doing this where everything
falls into place.
He's constantly getting exercise because
he's hiking and chasing after these
Caribou,
but that there's natural human reward
systems that are in place in his DNA for
hunting and gathering and cooking this
food over an open fire and the way he
lives.
He just,
he just thinks it's the way people
really are designed to live.
We're absolutely not meant to live,
piled on top of each other within,
you know,
10 million of us in a square mile and
the island of Manhattan,
you know?
Absolutely.
Do you remember when there was the
floods in Manhattan?
Yes.
All the money in the world couldn't get
you out.
Right?
You have to walk across the Brooklyn
Bridge to leave Manhattan with everybody
else.
Yeah.
You know?
And there was a real worry because of
climate change that was going to be
happening every year.
Now.
People were like,
is this the new normal?
I remember Shane Smith at some piece of
the walkout.
Yeah.
Shane had to walk out and.
But he had some piece on vice where they
were detailing the inside of his,
uh,
apartment building.
Like the fucking thing was completely
flooded like six feet high and water,
you know,
and people were worried,
worried like this is going to be what's
happening on a regular basis.
Now this climate change thing has
changed.
I have a heightened sense of,
uh,
you know,
since I have three kids,
I,
it's something that I think about.
It's something that I have ready.
You know,
I bought a generator.
I have,
I checked the batteries are rechargeable
batteries for all of the that I have.
I
own solar panels,
I own the Duffel bag full of everything
that I need to throw in the back of my
pickup truck,
grabbed my kids and I know which way to
drive away from the city to go to the
cabin.
It's something I've planned just because
I'm the ward of these small humans whom
I love.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny you talked about like
restriction again and the thing just I'm
thinking of preparing,
you know,
and the most common thing that people
prepare his food and prepare cans and
cans and cans of food,
but still they eat so much of that food
that the best way to prepare,
the best way to prepare would be to
start to eat less and learn how to live
at 1700 calories,
you know,
and learn how to live with the people
around you because if you're going to
spend like two months in the bunker or
in a bug out location or whatever,
you're not some asshole to your kids and
your friends and family and people with
you.
One of the things that happens to
people,
this is really fascinating when,
when disasters do strike,
because everyone gets a lot friendlier.
You know,
and this is one thing that I've
experienced myself this week because uh,
when we got evacuated,
it was 2:30
in the morning on Thursday and there was
fire a rock's throw from my house.
And I'm not talking a little bit of
fire.
I'm talking to hundreds of acres of
I mean it was just roaring over.
We started to see houses started seeing
the gas lines explode.
Houses burst into flames and it was
right down the street.
So we're seeing this and you know,
we're,
we got outside,
we're in the driveway.
The neighbors come over,
everyone's talking,
what are you going to do?
I go,
we're getting the fuck out of here.
And he's like,
have they given the evacuation orders?
I said,
no,
we haven't,
but I go,
it's right there,
man.
I go,
we gotta go.
if it,
if we're wrong and we come back in,
the house is still here.
That's okay,
but you want to get out of these things
quickly because they can turn south
quickly.
But there was this sense of comradery
and community that that happens and then
quite a few of us all went to the same
hotel,
including my friend Tom Segura and his
wife and his family went to this hotel
too with some of my friends from this
neighborhood who were all there huddled
in together and.
But there was,
there wasn't.
People were a little extra friendly.
There was a.
This is like a.
There was the same kind of feeling after
nine slash 11 when I was in New York
City.
There was people are little bit more
friendly.
We felt that during the ice storm back
in the day,
people were like I saying the street
that we live on,
and then they go,
well,
who's got a wood burning stove?
And they go,
oh,
Roger does come over and then people
would go to Roger's house and all of a
sudden all these neighbors that just
wave at each other,
we're all at Roger's house by the wood
burning stove,
going back to the houses to get
blankets,
planning,
sleeping arrangements,
planning food arrangements,
and assessing each other,
giving each other their personal space
and learning how to speak to each other
and a respect of mattered that we might
have to do this for several days and
through the through tragedy,
a sense of community was built somewhat
or reinforced for a brief moment in time
which made going back to our regular
lives on that street better.
Yeah.
You know?
If you ever read,
uh,
Sebastian younger's tribe,
no,
it's a great book,
and he kind of talks about that,
about how in part situations of extreme
stress and when people are really
pushed,
those people bond together and they find
that these are the happiest times of
their life.
People that even go to war,
they find that they missed the comradery
of the bunker.
They admit the miss,
the camaraderie of being in the
trenches.
They missed the camaraderie of being
together,
huddled up,
not knowing what's going to happen in
the future,
but counting and dependent upon each
other for their very live.
So that's a thing that happens in very,
very,
very busy kitchens.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
a bunch of no education guys out of
cooking school,
working a,
a difficult restaurant line,
you know,
we're working six guys,
six,
four burner stove every night.
A difficult menu with a difficult chef
and a very busy restaurant.
Those,
those,
those hours,
you know,
from 6:00
PM till 10:00
PM at night,
like it's intimate.
It's intimate.
Like,
you know,
like you're bending over to get into the
stove to get a chicken out.
I'm grabbing something out of the
fridge.
My nose is in your,
but your nose is in my,
but uh,
you know,
uh,
I,
I need your knife.
You need my knife.
Uh,
it's very,
very,
very close.
Quarter is often like some of my
strongest relationships.
Some of his strongest relationships are,
you know,
the bond that I built with guys that
I've cooked on lines,
whether in Europe or here are
unbreakable.
You know,
these guys got your back.
Tony talked a lot about that,
you know?
Yeah.
I think people are better off when
they're struggling.
I really do.
I mean,
I think they're better off when they're,
they're,
you know,
when life creates challenges and
there's,
there's things to overcome and there's
difficulties to get through and there's
real pressure involved in these.
And there's physical activity involved
in these pressure.
Something growing on the Galley,
the century and in the cat of nine tails
looming over.
Were you,
well all the years you guys had been in
business,
now what,
what do you look forward to now?
Like what,
what keeps you going?
Now you have this established
restaurant,
this amazing menu,
and you know,
you have fans of your restaurant like
myself.
What,
what keeps you going?
Tiny restaurant where David and I cook,
you know,
like,
uh,
you saw the movie,
the French connection?
Yes.
You see when Lachman's on the other side
of the road,
it's like freezing in New York.
He's in the Deli with a piece of pizza
and a shitty coffee.
His little leather shoes on the icy
pavement and then the French gangsters
or in the Bistro in the eating like
snails and eclairs and like all the food
that comes into the little crock pots on
the cart at the table.
If we could open a place like that for
like 16 customers that we have the key
only we decide to open whenever we want
and we don't lose money.
That's all I,
I like.
I want to build with Fred,
a tiny little French restaurant that we
do what we want.
16 seats an art project or I can take it
four or eight or close it or just a toy
to just practice this skill that we've
learned all of these years to do this
very,
very weird old for gotten food that's
not cool,
but that I adore.
You know what,
what are you like?
What is in the back of your head that
you don't bring to Joe Beef?
Oh,
you know,
one that everybody would know.
But to do a proper lamb.
Wellington served for two people and a
little trolley distill,
bring out the 12 cheeses on the little
trolley to have a trolley just of dst
crave to do crepes.
Tableside to do a duck lumbago to with
orange sauce.
Tableside for two.
You so it Tony.
We went to the [inaudible] place in
Quebec City and the first show in the
first parts unknown and it was
wonderful,
like little land goose flung Baden.
Like there were skills like we want to
be able to like just this morning we'll
do Tartara and will be mixed table side
and that's it.
Or Dover souls are really practice
hospitality at the level that it used to
be back in the day to bring out the very
old porcelain,
very beautiful silver,
not ostentatious way,
just almost in like a kitschy roadmap at
a kitschy,
romantic,
kind of nostalgic,
nostalgic sense.
What,
you know,
to build a restaurant from the twenties,
do that food.
Hadn't written menu flowers on it,
you know,
like,
yeah,
the appreciation that you guys have for
it is very contagious.
It really is.
Dining is great.
Like,
you know,
candle it dining,
it's odd,
you know,
heavy velvet woodwork,
silver trays,
copper,
uh,
just having way ask who's the other big
guy with a orson welles ever see those
morrison?
Well,
interviews at the hotel,
Pierre in Paris.
Those are just brilliant.
Like you want to just eat yourself to
death at hotel Pierre and how,
what he did.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's the only way we could build a time
travel machine.
Right?
Like you read about it.
It's fun when you go to museum,
when they see you,
you see like silverware for sunken ship.
Yeah.
That's nice.
But we'll never traveled back in time,
nor do I want to get polio,
you know,
there's great,
great benefits to living now.
And then now in here,
you know,
the art of it.
Yeah.
And,
and the beauty of it,
it's like we've grown up watching like
this old house,
Victory Gardens,
all those shows on pbs.
We're huge fans.
And the beauty of this is we can build a
restaurant like that,
but our hands.
So we,
it's just a matter of is it this year?
Is it next year?
You know what,
we were doing it now,
by the way.
Yeah.
Are you?
Yeah,
we bought it.
I bought a farm and he's going to read.
I bought a farm I bought,
but Fred a farm for me is what the gag
is.
Where are you guys?
Gonna do it.
I think down in St Dharma that I bought
a little farm right on the Vermont
border,
but there's a summer kitchen part as
beautiful a brick,
a wood burning oven situation and a big
window.
Uh,
an old factory rod iron window.
Or the room is just begging to have like
three tables of four or three tables of
four and a little stove and the zinc
bar.
And uh,
I don't know.
He's been cracking out.
He's talking about going down there in
January and starting to build it.
This is the polar opposite of the theme
restaurant in Vegas.
T gif.
Not just that,
but like the,
the celebrity chef as you're going down
the escalator at the airport,
there's a giant billboard of this
latest.
Did you ever hear this story about the
Fertitta brothers would know.
So they,
they called Fred one day and they said,
we're coming to Montreal.
Uh,
we'd love to meet you guys ever like,
yeah,
okay.
I'm really what's going on.
You know,
we're not open for this.
Last year,
last year after they sold,
I think they bought the poems.
They have cash the whole.
And they're great guys.
I love those guys.
It's fast.
Okay,
wonderful.
You get ahold of you.
So they got to fly into privately to
the,
to the airport.
Montreal.
Three escalades roll into Joe beef at
noon on a Tuesday.
Uh,
all the boys get out a plus help and you
know,
the crew over that surrounds them since.
Yeah,
we make a table of 10.
We all sit down.
Lorenzo starts off first,
I'd like to let you guys know that Joe
beef is my favorite restaurant and I'm
like,
what,
you know this dump your Lorenzo Fertitta
all over the world live in Las Vegas.
Everything is at your Beck and call like
you live in the,
you know,
so that was flattering,
and we prepared a little dinner for
them,
a little lunch and do we talk.
Then they pitched us to take over one of
the rooms and the palms upstairs and uh,
of course I always flattering we had a
wonderful meeting but we knew right away
as we were having the meeting and that
was not for us and it was never going to
happen.
We have young children and we're in a
bad place to at the time was tough in
our life,
you know,
still
drinking.
Still not.
Yeah,
it was pretty dark,
but it was nice and flattering and I
think fred moved them onto mark Vacherie
who eventually did the project from
Philadelphia and in retrospect,
uh,
yeah,
I was nice flattering,
but we wouldn't do that.
Yeah,
there's no way we couldn't do joe beef
anywhere else.
People don't eat.
The dining public doesn't exist unless,
unless it's on my street.
So Montreal is just such a different
place.
The idea is like when before they
offered any a room there,
I said,
is there like a decommission laundromat
in the back?
That's where employees only that reset
all the wrong things mad at 800 square
feet that we can make a five table
French restaurant.
They're pitching us the top floor of the
palms and we're asking for the door next
to the garbage container in the alley
with no windows and they were looking at
us like we're insane table for trust
rather than his brother and his brother
was looking at Lorenzo like,
fuck,
we sent them some books.
Now I'm sure they're happy.
He's such a funny,
funny way of responding to that.
We want to give you the top four,
the palms in Vegas.
Do you have for fucking 800 hundred
square foot room and the back alley that
nobody could access?
I wouldn't make it so expensive that
basketball players think it's too much
money.
Well,
that would be a very interesting spot
and I'm sure it would if,
if you did create something like that or
someone did an unbelievably exclusive
spot that literally has 20 seats
available in a night and they only open
for one sitting right there and we want
to build the.
What's the,
the movie the Roxbury.
We want to build the French connection.
That restaurant all the other one with j
dot lo.
What's that one?
Gigli.
Ishtar made major Manhattan.
Yeah,
I mean I guarantee if someone did do
something like that,
particularly because of Vegas,
it's all about who you know and who you.
I mean,
if you can get in,
you know,
you can get into Joe Lamb.
Oh,
it's Joe Lammas in Vegas.
It's right behind the garbage container.
The leaky one.
Next to the grease trap.
Yeah.
Girls and they're Jimmy Choo's have to
step through these puddles of greys.
Louboutin on their way to the back.
Then it would,
ironically enough,
it would be probably the hot spot in
Vegas.
I know Joel,
what?
Lorenzo didn't get it probably wouldn't
be very profitable though.
I mean obviously.
Well when they took over the palms,
I was excited.
I know that nine steakhouse there was
excellent.
I haven't been there in years,
but I used to be a great place,
but mark was there.
Mark Veggies,
an excellent cook.
He's really involved in like solid
charity things.
I think he's also brown or black belt in
Jujitsu.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's a veteran guy.
Resourceful dude.
Wow.
So did he.
So he is the restaurant
open A.
I think this week it was a swing or.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's fantastic.
That's awesome.
Wow.
And his food is delicious.
Try it out.
Yeah.
Batteries in Philadelphia as an
institution.
We opened like a.
There was one thing when,
when we.
What was this?
What was the story of the lobster
spaghetti?
You know,
we took that kind of like,
there was a story in Bon appetit
magazine about love at my mark vettery
doing lobster Spaghetti and fighting
with his dad about removing a table to
put a meat slicer in reading.
They have 24 seats and he bought a nice
red slicer and he said,
we're taking out four seats and now
we're down to 20 seats.
His Dad thought he was insane ad,
but he insisted that you know,
they have 20 seats instead of 24.
We.
That story was endearing to Fred and I
and he was doing a lobster.
Spaghetti is Philadelphia restaurant at
the time.
So when we open joe beef,
one of the first items on the menu was
our version of the lobster spaghetti
that mark vettery was doing.
And just a simple homage to that story.
Later,
years later we met him and we told them
the story and became friends.
That's amazing.
So why did it take for seats?
What does,
what does this thing look like?
Well,
you know,
you seen those big Italian red burchell
a meat slicers.
No,
Berkeley.
So did he do it?
Just because it would add to the
ambiance to have this cool thing in
Italy.
This is a pretty standard piece of
equipment that you'd have on the bars.
Does it turns slow?
It's a big blade that rotates slowly.
Very,
very sharp.
So it doesn't a pinwheel.
Yeah.
It doesn't melt the fat of the Ham.
Right.
So you don't get this white film.
So it makes like perfectly thin cool
slices of perfect ham.
Either a gorgeous objects like we have a
couple now we have a blue one and we
have a red one.
They're gorgeous for me.
Jamie.
Cutting meat.
That one's nice.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
you know I saw one of these in Italy.
Yeah,
sure.
They're all over the place.
Yeah.
When,
when I was in Italy I saw one of these.
There were,
there were making sandwiches with it.
Yeah.
But that's 10,000,
$15,000
machine.
So when you,
when you removed four seats from your
restaurant and put one of those in,
you kind of like,
you know,
it's stepping up.
You're on the wrong side of business.
Job Point.
You're on the right side of business.
Um,
you guys have something going on
tonight,
right?
No,
no,
no.
We did last night.
We cooked that animal last night in Las
Vegas.
That was cool.
Yeah,
those guys are great.
It's awesome.
And then they were never been.
Yeah.
And things.
Yeah,
they're good boys.
They have John and vinny is across the
street animals at restaurant that kind
of opened around the same time.
Joe Beef,
we were friends back then.
Uh,
they came up to Montreal a bunch of
times.
I brought them to all the weird.
We're all kindred spirits.
It's like the same day they did the
restaurant business,
like we practiced the restaurant
business.
The restaurant is so similar to ours and
weird ways and their John and vinny
is a very.
Dave and Fred.
It's strange,
like it's a law if you have these sort
of connections with these fellow
likeminded chefs.
All the pirates.
Antonis captain.
Tony's pirate ship man.
Yeah.
Well he was the one who introduced me to
you guys.
Yeah.
You told me about you guys listen,
uh,
Joe beef,
surviving the apocalypse.
Is it out now?
Computer a week.
Twenty fourth,
24th.
So vendor,
I have it already.
You fucks sorry,
but you're going to have to wait,
but please go out,
go buy it.
Support.
And if you're in Montreal,
go visit my best restaurant,
Joe beef.
You guys are the shit.
Thank you,
Joe.
Thank you very much.
Very,
very much.
Thank you.